[Musique]
Bertrand Badré bonsoir bonsoir nous vous
recevons pour une chaîne internet qui
s'appelle Serview nous sommes en direct
est-ce que vous pouvez vous présenter
succintement
bonsoir oui alors moi j'ai 55 ans et euh
tout a commencé précisément sur le lieu
la date de ma naissance je suis né en
mai 68 à Versailles et ça a assez
largement polarisé ma vie depuis euh je
me suis la première fois que j'ai
présenté un examen on m' demandé de
donner ma carte d'identité ah mais vous
êtes né en M68 à versaill ce dont je
n'avais pas pris conscience à ce
moment-là ça va être intéressant de voir
si cette discussion nous permet
déterminer si vous être plus mes 68 ou
Versailles et en fait 55 ans plus tard
je ne sais toujours pas euh
et donc c'est vrai que ça a orienté
d'une j' dire côté vers ça d'une
certaine manière un parcours scolaire
assez classique vue- de France euh HC
sciencep et l'Inspection des finances
banque d'affaires et cetera euh côté mes
68 une interrogation permanente pour
savoir si le système dans lequel j'ai
été placé est le bon système est-ce
qu'il faut le remettre en question
est-ce qu'il faut le challenger comme on
dit comme on dit en franlais et ce qui
fait que j'ai fini par créer euh sur le
tard ma start-up avec mes associés qui
s'appelle orange BL orang c'est très mes
68 puis que c'est une référence à Paul
Eluard
poète surréaliste évidemment qui avait
écrit la terre est bleue comme une
orange on a d'ailleurs eu des
discussions avec ses descendants qui
nous disit quand même notre grand-père
communiste aurait pas aimé que son nom
serve à une entreprise financière don
vous voyez on est dans espèce de melting
pot et donc voilà je navigue entre ces
les deux pôles versaill versaill et et
mes 68 plus plus prosaïquement donc j'ai
j'ai passé l'essentiel de ma vie
profession
à explorer les différents quartiers de
la finance dans un de mes livres
d'ailleurs de de manière à la fois un
peu prétentieuse et un peu malicieuse je
me compare à Forest gum en fait je me
suis trouvé là où ça se passait quand ça
se passait sans jamais le planifier
j'étais au ministère des Finances à
Paris quand on préparait l'eurau à une
position évidemment très junior j'étais
à Londres donc en 1999 2000 au moment ça
c'est vraiment pour les plus vieux de
ceux qui nous écoutent la nouvelle
économie donc la bulle la nouvelle
économie bu internet la bulle Internet
la première bulle Internet j'étais à New
York peu après quand cette fameuse bulle
Internet a explosé juste avant
d'ailleurs que le World Trade Center
explose et je l'ai vu effectivement la
fenêtre de mes bureaux
j'ai été un an au cabinet du président
Jacques Chirac l'année de la guerre en
Irak et il se trouve que pour des
raisons purement immobilières mon bureau
était placé dans la cellule diplomatique
à côté des gens qui discutaient de ce
qu'on faisait avec les États-Unis pour
d'abord prévenir puis après suivre la
guerre en Irak j'ai ensite été euh de
nouveau banquier d'affaires et j'ai
travaillé plusieurs années sur la
restructuration d'Eurotunnel alors là
aussi c'est vraiment pour les plus
anciens de nos auditeurs mais Eurotunnel
c'était un scandale permanent de
pratiquement sa construction jusqu'à la
restructuration que j'ai contribué à
mené en 2007 et ensuite j'ai été pendant
6 ans directeur financier des groupes
crédit agricoes puis Société générale
pendant la crise financière mondiale
donc j'ai vu le monde s'effondrer sous
mes pieds pendant toutes ces années
j'étais au première loges euh j'essayie
de prendre des notes et bon j'en ai tiré
quelques réflexions ensuite et après je
suis parti à Washington toujours forest
gum j'étais directeur général de la
Banque mondiale entre 2013 et 2016 et
précisément au moment où les bricks on
aura peut-être l'occasion d'en reparler
émergai les ont créé la fameuse banque
des bricks la banque du Brésil de la
Russie de l'Inde de la Chine et de
l'Afrique du Sud où les Chinois créent
leur propre banque concurrente de la
Banque mondiale et donc je me retrouvais
là au moment où tout ça se passait sous
mes yeux j'étais aux États-Unis au
moment où Trump est élu et puis voilà
puis après directeur général de la
banque mon voà directeur Gén la B mon
puis après une pause d'un an dans un S
tank et puis après création de de Blue
like and orange fond d'investissement
dans le développement durable pour
l'instant en Amérique latine et bientôt
en Afrique bon avant qu'on aborde des
sujets qui font un peu mal à la finance
je vais je vais d'abord essayer de vous
cuisiner sur la chute de Rome et sur les
mémoires d'Adrien
et ensuite je voudrais savoir que veut
dire pour vous le prétexte de nurbert
alors alors on commence par la chute de
Rome on commence par la chute de Rome
alors la la la chute de Rome c'est une
des citations qui aujourd'hui m'empêche
de dormir alors je vais aller jusqu'au
bout de de la citation en fait les
mémoires d'Adrien c'est un des livres
qui m'a qui m'a beaucoup marqué
Marguerite Marguerite hursenard pardon
euh c'est un livre qui m'a beaucoup
marqué que j'ai lu quand j'étais lycéen
que j'ai relu pendant le covid donc
c'était et je suis tombé sur cette
citation de mémoire donc Adrien empereur
romain du 2e siècle c'est le c'est le
sommet de l'Empire romain en terme
culturel en terme de taille de l'Empire
euh donc marguerite hursenard se met
dans la peau de l'empereur Adrien c'est
un livre qu'elle écrit en 1955 ou 1956
et réfléchit il est dans sa villa Tivoli
à rom il réfléchit il médite sur
l'exercice du pouvoir et il médite sur
le le destin de Rome et il se dit la
chute de Rome va arriver euh
voilà puis quand écrit en 1955 c'est pas
compliqué de se dire qu'Adrien s'est dit
que la chute elle est arrivé bon sa pas
mais il se dit comment puis-je retarder
ce moment comment puis-je retarder ce
moment où les barbares au dehors et les
esclaves au dedans se ruront sur un
monde qu'on leur demande de respecter de
loin ou de servir d'en bas et il ajoute
et pourtant j'aimerais qu'ils aiment
Rome alors je cite de mémoire mais c'est
à peu près ça et et pour moi c'est
c'était un choc quand j'ai relu cette
cette ce passage pendant le covid alors
évidemment euh ce ce qui est amusant
c'est que j'ai j'ai cité cette ce
passage dans le livre que j'ai écrit euh
à la fin du covid et mon éditeur m'a dit
quand même barbare et esclave c'est pas
trè très politiquement correct c'est
quand même Marguerite hursona bon ok
alors on va garder euh mais c'est vrai
que si on remplace Barbar par pays en
développement esclave par par en gros
les gens les les sendant lescendant
comme aurait dit peut-être le président
enfin en tout cas les populations les
plus défavorisées chez nous et si on
remplace Rome par Europe ou Occident ça
marche assez bien enfin c'est vraiment
la question à laquelle on est confronté
comment alors qu'on est face à des défis
considérables on embarque tout le monde
et comment on fait que on se contente
pas de dire mais en fait ça va puisqueen
fait ils envies l'Occident en fait ils
ont envie d'être comme nous et ça suffit
pas donc voilà pour voilà pour
Marguerite hursenard et et Adrien et
pour la petite histoire quand j'habitais
aux États-Unis euh j'ai voulu aller sur
la tombe de Marguerite hursenard euh
dans le Main à M désert où elle a habité
et c'est très très compliqué parce que
c'est un cimetière américain la plouse
j'ai mis 2 heures à trouver sa tombe
j'étais avec ma fille qui regardait sa
monde qui dit pasattendre encore pour
longtemps pour trouver la tombe et j'ai
fini par trouver une toute petite plaque
Margerite hursenard
recouverte par les herbes c'était un
moment d'émotion intense j'étais
vraiment
très très grand moment le prétexte de
nurbert alors le prétexte de nurbert
c'est c'est une anecdote et et c'est Mar
parce que quand vous me posez la
question j'ai j'ai encore un tremblement
j'ai senti mes jambes
se rappeler ce moment-là
en fait c'est l'excuse de nurbert c'est
c'est le le contexte c'est avril 2008
donc on est pour ceux qui ont qui ont
une bonne mémoire on est avant la
faillite de les man Brothers 15
septembre 2008 et après ce qu'on croyait
être la crise du subprime c'était le
moment où il y avait un petit doute pour
savoir après tout ça y est c'est encore
une crise financière on a mis de
l'argent dans le système et on va passer
à autre chose donc en fait il y avait un
espèce de lâche soulagement on est passé
à une étape on a eu un peu peur mais on
a ouvert les robinets les robinets ont
marché l'incendie est éteint une espèce
de moment entre entre avril mai et et
juillet de cette année-là et donc
l'Institut montaagne je crois organisé à
Paris je crois que c'était dans le siège
d'Axa euh un colloque euh sur la crise
du Suprême c'était bon voilà on a une
crise quelle leçon peut-on en tirer euh
donc il m'avait demandé j'étais à
l'époque directeur financier du Crédit
Agricole il m'avait demandé de
participer à la préparation moi ça
m'intéressait intellectuellement j'avais
été plein dans ces sujetsl et parmi les
personnes qu'on invite on invite Paul
Volker alors Paul Volker c'était le
président de la Réserve fédérale
américaine de 1979 à 1987
nommé par Jimmy Carter confirmé par
Ronald Reagan al Paul Volker c'est le
prototype du grand serviteur de l'État
américain grand parce que d'abord il
fait plus de 2 m et puis il est très
imposant puis c'est vraiment la grande
figure publique américaine ENF intègre
vent jamais questionné sur sa probité et
il est crédité d'avoir été celui qui a
cassé l'inflation en augmentant très
fortement les taux d'intérêt à 8080 en
provoquant une récession et c'est et
c'est de lui qu'on reparle aujourd'hui
parce que comm on reparle d'inflation
aujourd'hui les gens se sont précipités
sur quel est le dernier gars qui a
réussi à bainre l'inflation et c'était
Paul Volker alors je peux vous couper
oui bien sûr donc le choc volkerer parce
que maintenant c'est comme ça qu'on
l'appelle ça a été jugulé l'inflation en
tuant la demande absolument et donc en
tuant la demande c'est-à-dire
en augmentant très fort les taux oui les
taux sont passés à 17 18 % et en tuant
le consommateur en tuant le consommateur
provoquant une récession massive un
chômage très élevé une chute de
l'investissement et
et en fait c'est c'est alors est-ce que
ça a causé la défaite de Jimmy Carter
puis les tensions chezan probablement
mais en tout cas il a cassé et et et
c'est vrai qu'après tout le monde l'a
sui y compris la France enfin la rigueur
de 83 en France c'est pas un copiercollé
mais mais presque de de ce qui s'était
passé aux États-Unis quelques quelques
années avant et donc Paul Volker
d'une certaine manière rappelé par
sera rappelé par Barack Obama à la fin
de l'année 2008 mais pendant la crise
financière c'est une des voix qui
s'élève sur cette crise en disant on a
un problème donc on est très heureux de
le faire venir à Paris
je me retrouve à côté de lui moi je suis
assez grand alors lui éit bon et dans
donc il fait son exposé j'ai plus le
détail en tête mais je me sens très bien
de la configuration de la salle c'est un
amphithéâtre en en sous-sol qui était
plein parce que évidemment c'étaitord
c'était une vedette et puis c'était un
sujet qui intéressait quand même et il y
a une question dans la salle qui dit qui
quelqu'un lève la main il dit Monsieur
Volker euh vous avez dit aux États-Unis
euh euh enfin vous êtes très critique
avec les banquiers les financiers enfin
vraiment que que en fait vous êtes
agressif avec une catégorie de la
population pourquoi est-ce que vous êtes
si agressif et et Paul Volker répond là
aussi je cite à peu près de mémoire euh
il dit écoutez je vais vous répondre ce
que j'ai répondu à mon Petitfils qui
travaille à Wall Street donc le
Petitfils de Paul walkker qui m'a dit
qui m'a dit la même posé la même
question grand-père pourquoi tu es
désagréable avec moi parce que je fais
que mon métier après tout et là il
regarde la salle il leur dit vous savez
je n'accepte pas plus en 2008 qu'en 1945
l'excuse de nbert alors cétait d'autant
plus fort que au premier rang il y avait
Samuel pizard donc survivantexcuse de N
voilà l'excuse de nurber pardon CIT for
que au premier r il y avait Samuel pizar
survivant dans des camps qui avait
contribué à organiser le colocque donc
il voyit très bien ce que l'excuse nbert
c'est en fait le le ce qu' an Aren t'a
mis en avant c'est c'est pas moi qui a
mis l'aiguillage en gros il y a un train
qui passait je savais pas ce qu'il y
avait dedans moi j'étais juste à
l'aiguillage et c'était au procès de
nurinbert les dirigeants naziis qui se
défaussai en disant bah c'était Hitler
c'était je sais pas qui enfin c'était
pas moi moi j'étais juste enfin j'étais
un rouage ou ou un pion sur les
chiquiers ou un rouage voilà et il a dit
j'accepte pas cette excuse de la part de
financier pas plus qu'elle n'était
valable à rber en 1945 pourquoi parce
que vous les financiers vous êtes en
moyenne très diplômé parmi même les plus
diplômés de la planète vous êtes les
mieux payer vous êtes les mieux informés
et vous allez pas en plus me faire
croire que vous savez pas ce que vous
faites là il y a un silence et moi je
c'est que c'est vraiment c'est c'est
quelque chose que j'ai beaucoup raconté
notamment à mes étudiants je dire ça
veut dire qu'il faut toujours vous
posiez la question de le système dans
lequel je suis j'y suis innocemment j'y
suis par accident ou je sais ce que je
fais et c'est pas simple parce que parce
que c'est un système qui pour faire très
court est un peu une cage dorée mais on
est bien dans une cage dorée donc c'est
compliqué de se poser des questions mais
pour moi c'est très important cétait un
moment je dis j'ai j'ai j'ai retremblé
en le en le remontant je me souviens
physiquement de Paul walkker disant ça
de Samuel pizar au premier rang quel
regard je vais dire tu ok quel regard tu
portes sur la spéculation sur les
matières premières alimenta
alors
il y a plusieurs choses d'ailleurs le le
mot spéculation il y a une spéculation
qui on passe sa vie à spéculer à savoir
si on va cher quelque chose aujourd'hui
parce que c'est moins cher que demain et
cetera c'est la vie de PRS tous les
êtres humains depuis qu'il a des êtres
humains sur la planète on fait des paris
sur l'avenir là où c'est un vrai
problème c'est quand la spéculation est
un sujet organisé alors quand ça prend
des formes d's parfois maximaliste je
sais pas si vous vous souvenez de ce
film 70 avec Jean Carmé qui s'appelait
le sucre où on dit on va cornériser un
marché donc quelqu'un dit je vais je
vais spéculer je vais acheter tout le
sucre disponible je faire monter les
prix et je libérer après donc ça c'est
épouvantable donc la la la ce qu'il faut
c'est faire fonctionner proprement les
marchés qui a un niveau de spéculation
qui permettre au marché de s'ajuster et
à la production augmenter quand elle
doit augmenter ou de baisser quand elle
doit baisser ce qui est absolument
scandaleux c'est quand c'est
instrumentalisé de manière décisive où
on va
en gros fausser le le fonctionnement
d'un marché proprement régulé ça ça
existe et ça depuis la Révolution
française il y a plein de livres qui ont
été écrits pour savoir si ça avait été
organisé ou pas jusqu'à aujourd'hui un
certain nombre de pays euh ça c'est très
lait ça c'est très la et et là aussi il
faut pas dire qu'on sait pas ce qu'on
fait c'est quand on fait de la hyper
frequency trading quand on se positionne
le plus proche
avoir une connexion très rapide bien sûr
moi c'est moi c'est quelque chose que
j'ai beaucoup beaucoup de mal à
comprendre bien sûr est-ce que est-ce
que les financiers que vous avez pu
côtoyer vous en avez parlé avec eux tu
en as parlé avec eux est-ce qu'il y a eu
des discussions autour de ça que ça peut
affamer certaines personnes que ça fait
augmenter les prix ailleurs que ça crée
de l'instabilité ils on rien à faire
c'est c'est loin de chez eux il ils s'en
rendent pas compte parce que c'est un
bouton d'ordinateur il voit pas les
conséquences dans la vie réelle comment
ça se passe est-ce que est-ce que tu as
des anecdotes là-dessus de manipulation
toutes les populations il y a des salots
et des seins ENF j'ai vraiment et et et
certains peuvent avoir été salot un jour
et sa un autre jour et certains peuvent
évoluer certains peuvent chuter et
d'autres trouver leur chemin de Damas et
changer et et puis la finance c'est
c'est c'est c'est un c'est un univers
qui est extraordinairement vaste entre
l'opérateur sur les marchés qui est en
gros un geek qui fait du High Frequency
trading et puis par exemple ce que je
fais qui est d'investir dans la santé au
Mexique ou en Équateur enfin ça
s'appelle finance ça a juste rien avoir
donc pour il faut revenir au aux
fondamentaux de de la finance et je
réfléchirai en même temps si j'ai des
anecdotes parce que j'en ai forcément
j'ai vu j'ai vu des gens d'un cinisme
épouvantable
la la finance qu
la racine c'est ce qui permet de se
projeter loin de iketnung de ici et
maintenant c'estàd par la finance je
peux dire depuis cette salle je peux
investir pour un projet dans 20 ans dans
un autre pays et ça il y a rien qui
permet c'est c'est l'outil qui nous
permet de nous projeter loin et et et
dans longtemps donc l'outil il est il
est neutre en je dire on en fait ce
qu'on veut à partir de là ce qui est
terrible c'est que comme tous les outils
c'est là qu'on en revient à urin vert
c'est comme tous les outils
le principe c'est que normalement c'est
la main qui contrôle l'outil et que la
main elle est contrôlée par le cerveau
bah il y a des il y a des gens qui
utilisent ces choses là de alors soit
excuseber en faisant semblant de pas
savoir ce qu'ils font ça c'est
épouvantable c'est les demiabiles
pascaliens soit les cyniques absolu mais
il y a évidemment des gens qui sont dans
cette catégorie moi j'ai rencontré je
encore une fois sur des opérations
financières qui n'avaient aucun sens et
cetera ça m'est arrivé de voir des gens
qui disent c'est pas grave on prend
notre com et cetera ça ça existe bien
sûr mais je pense pas qu'il fait jeter
le discrédit sur l'ensemble de la
population financière pour autant je
crois vraiment euh et c'est pour ça que
j'avais pas très bien réagi al c'était
pas une réaction corporatiste quand
quand François Hollande qui était pas
encore président avait avait dit j'ai un
ennemi la finance enans visage et cetera
euh
voilà c'était de la formule sur de la
formule sur de la formule euh
c'était trop simple pour un sujet qui
mérite quand même qu'on rentre dans le
détail et qu'on regarde il y a vraiment
tellement de choses derrière mot finance
depuis l'agence du Crédit Agricole à
Saint-Flour jusqu'au high frequency
trading à Wall Street ça s'appelle tout
finance ça a juste rien à voir
est-ce que vous avez été témoin de
manipulation de marché est-ce que vous
avez été témoins de bidouillage dans
dans les salle est-ce que alors moi j'ai
jamais été dans les marchés euh j'étais
directeur financier de banque dans
lesquels il y avait des départements de
marché j'avais des départements de
trésorerie qui me qui me rapportaient
mais pour le coup c'était pour gérer
l'argent de la banque la la banque
qutidien j'ai pas de
après il y a eu pour le coup moi j'ai
été j'ai vu des opérations financières
qui nous ont coûté d'ailleurs on c'est
c'était d'ailleurs
je me souviens je je disais ça en 2008
ce qui est intéressant vous vous
souvenez comment a commencé l'année 2008
avec Kerviel et comment elle a fini avec
madof
et et et et c'est amusant parce que
Cariel n'était pas madof hein non non
mais ce que ce qui était intéressant
c'est que euh quand j'étais au Crédit
Agricole c'est vraiment une période
j'étais très heureux j'allais
pratiquement pas toutes les semaines
mais presque dans une caisse régionale
donc j'ai passé 3 4 ans à aller tout
toutes les caisses de France j'ai été du
Havre à Périgueux de Toulouse à Grenoble
au puit partout et et en fait c'est
intéressant parce que la crise
financière c'est quand même très
compliqué c'est difficile même si
prêtait des talents de vulgarisateur
j'essaie d'expliquer ce qui se passait
alors qu'en fait madof et kvia les gens
comprenaient très bien et en fait vous
avez eu des t-shirts avec madof et Merel
vous avez pas eu des t-shirts avec lman
enfin c'était les gens avaient besoin de
voir une face un visage une histoire
alors évidemment que kviel c'était pas
madof et madof c'était pas kviel il y
avait aussi je me sui un gros scandale
dans le golf avec une je sais plus les
détail qui s'appelait algosbi c'était de
l'arnaque pure et simple ENF c'est des
gens qui s'étaient fait avoir sur des
projets qui existaient pas de la
corruption du trafic ça ça existe
malheureusement euh madof c'est quand
même un truc extraordinaire le gars il a
il a planté 50 milliards sur 20 ans ans
et moi je me souviens quand j'ai habitaé
à New York quelques années avant madof
c'était un nom très respectable les
genens on parlit avec oh là là c'est le
mec donc voilà il y a des gens qui
profitent je pense que madof c'est
typiquement quelqu'un qui a profité pour
ceux qui ne connaissent pas madof une
pyramide de Ponzi à l'ancienne
absolument on est à la barbe de tout le
monde voilà et pire encore parce que non
seulement donc pyramide de Ponzi le
système c'est en général c'est connu
mais pour ceux qui ne connaîtrai pas une
pyramide de Ponzi c'est je lève de
l'argent je promets un rendement les
gens ex voilà donnez-moi de l'argent et
je vous donne 10 % tous les ans c'est
formidable 10 % tous les ans donc je
vous donne de l'argent et chaque année
il faut que je récolte un peu plus et
avec l'argent que je récolte je paye les
premiers pas la pyramide ça monte tous
les ans et ça peut durer longtemps
puisque dans le cas de madov c'est plus
de 20 ans pendant 20 ans il était
capable de récolter de l'argent de
renvoyer et ce qui est extraordinaire
c'est qu'il y a eu un certain nombre de
dénonciation il y a des gens qui avaient
parfaitement compris que ce truc ne
pouvait pas marcher il y a aucun système
financier qui vous garantit une telle
régularité de rendement ça n'existe pas
que que année de crise pas année de
crise c'était toujours les mêmes sans
aucune variationf c'est et donc la SCC
donc l'autorité de marché américaine a
envoyé des inspecteurs qui n'ont rien vu
c'est extraordinaire
et il a fallu c'était moi c'est la le
théorème que que que que j'aime beaucoup
et on peut le réemployer encore encore
cette année de Warren Buffett je sais
pas si c'est un théorème si vous
connaissez cette phrase que que j'aime
bien qui dit buffet c'était qui alors
Warren Buffett
c'est le le gourou ultime des marchés
aujourd'hui il a 94
15 ans quelque chose comme ça on
l'appelle l'oracle d'omaa omaa c'est
dans le Nebraska c'est c'est un état du
Middle West américain plus célèbre pour
son maïs et son blé que pour mais aussi
pour ses compagnies d'assurance mutuell
et Warren Buffett c'est un investisseur
qui qui qui maintenant le principal
action une entreprise s'appelle bersher
ataw qui est une très grosse holding et
qui qui qui chaque année ses investir
l'action de j'ai le cours aujourd'hui
mais vaut 200000 dollars enfin c'est et
les gens achètent et vont avec ça
écouter waren Buffett chacque année qui
explique ce qui se passe waren Buffett
donc c'est vraiment la personne qui qui
a commencé en investissant un peu il y a
60 ans quelque chose comme ça et qui
aujourd'hui ça berarata est probement
une des entreprises les plus valorisées
au monde ça ça vaut je vais pas dire des
bêtises mais probablement dehord de 500
milliards aujourd'hui et et donc Warren
Buffett il a il dit moi j'investis dans
les choses que je comprends donc il a
investi chez Coca-Cola il a investi chez
Apple il dit moi je veux comprendre le
produit donc lui c'est lui qui avait dit
les produits dérivé ces armes de
destruction massives c'est et donc waren
Buffett avait cette formule très très
intéressante il a dit c'est quand la
marée baisse qu'on voit qu'il se baigne
sans maillot ou qu'on voit les cadavres
je sais pas s'il a dit les cadavres mais
mais en tout cas il a dit c'est quand la
Maré baisse qu'on se baigne qu'on voit
ceux qui se baignent sans maillot et je
me souviens j'avais eu j'allais voir une
caisse je sais plus laquelle du crédit
agricole à la fin de l'année 2008 après
la fê de les man Brothers j'avais ajouté
ce qui avit pas mal fait rire et on
s'est rendu compte qu'on était dans un
camp de naturiste personne av'ait de
maillot en fait et en fait c'est ça ce
qui s'est passé madof sans crise il
aurait pu durer 10 ans de plus et et
kviel probablement aussi c'est quand
quand brusquement les choses se
dérèglent que que ce qui était caché
mais kviel c'est une autre affaire non
non mais je je parle de l'affaire du
fait que ça se voit et on a eu la même
chose ces dernières années là l'année
2022 2023 on a eu exactement le même
phénomène les taux d'intérêt qui avait
baissé pendant des années les taux
d'intérêt remontent effectivement quand
les taux d'intérêt baissent et que
l'argent est gratuit fait pas très
attention puis brusquement ça monte et
là brusquement le Crédit Suisse
disparaît Crédit Suisse disparaît en un
weekend il avvez trois banques
américaines silicon valleybank et
quelques autres qui disparaissent c'est
pareil c'est la marée vous avez vous
rappelez peut-être de l'AST trus
l'éphémère Premier ministre britannique
qui par ses par ses déclarations un peu
intempestiv fait complètement dévier le
marché des des des SMS avec Nordstream
ou non non non non non je parle de du
fait qu'elle a une politique économique
où elle dit on va faire des baisses
d'impôts massives enfin en gros elle dit
moi je vais relancer l'économie
britannique par une relance massive on
est en plein brexit et dit on va baisser
les impôts on va augmenter les dépenses
elle se souvient pas que le
Grande-Bretagne est toute seule est plus
il y a plus l'Europe il y a rien et là
le marché obligataire Bou desvis et et
là on découvre que les fonds de pension
avec des systèmes qui les protégé qui et
ça marche plus et donc en 15 jours
dististus s'en va et la marée a montré
effectivement le quand quand la marée
baisse ah bah tiens on avait pas vu
qu'il y avait des tuyaux qui marchaient
pas et cetera enfin je veux dire on peut
continuer les exemples comme ça mais ce
qui était extraordinaire avec cette
crise de 2008 c'est qu'effectivement on
a vu bah on a vu effectivement le le
camp naturiste le fait que on était pas
bien et c'est là qu'on a dû faire appel
à la puissance publique et et c'est là
qu' y a un ressenti extrêmement brutal
profondément enraaciné chez les gens qui
savent pas forcément explicit parce que
c'est des mécaniques compliquées
globalement ils se disent
on les a sauvés
what for et moi qu'est-ce qu'on a fait
donc les riches les puissants les
banques on les a sauvés et pour moi
l'anecdote elle est très intéressante
c'est une anecdote enfin c'est une
anecdote c'est le cas français que j'ai
pu tester un peu partout sur la planète
il y a eu les équivalents partout sur la
planète je sais pas si vous vous
souvenez de ce dont on parlait à l'été
2008 en France du RSA bravo on parlait
du RSA Martin HCH au commissaire
solidarité active et la question c'est
de savoir si on allait faire un RSA
généraliser à tout le territoire ou si
on faisait un pilote dans une région
est-ce que ça coûtait 300 millions ou
600 millions enfin les ordres de
grandeur c'était ça c'était entre 500
millions et 1 milliard tout l'été été
2008 juste avant la faillite de le man
brotherows on s'interroge sur ce RSA
arrive la faillite de le MAN browers de
15 septembre le 3 octobre je crois
Nicolas Sarkozi Christine Lagarde
annonce le plan plan de soutien au
financement de l'économie on nallait pas
dire plan de soutien aux banques quand
même financement de l'économie c'était
mieux donc plan de soutien au
financement de l'économie et annonce des
chiffres considérables parce qu'il
fallait c'était l'effet dynamite en gros
il fallait tuer l'idée que ça pouvait
sauter donc on dit on va mobiliser 420
milliards d'euros alors évidemment quand
on rentre dans le détail 420 milliards
d'euros il y avait de l'argent en direct
par exemple pour Dexia on a plus
beaucoup parler d'eux enfin céit de
l'argent direct il y avait des garanties
y avait il y avait une panopliie de
mais 420 milliards d'euros c'est
beaucoup alors évidemment quand quand
vous allez parler à des non spécialistes
que j'ai fait il quand même 420
milliards alors moi je faisais je
prenais ma casquette un peu technique
j'ai 420 milliards c'est comme si c'est
comme ça et d'ailleurs l'État va gagner
de l'argent ce qui est vrai l'État a
gagner de l'argent à terme mais
fondamentalement quand les gens me
disaient mais on comprend pas on met 2
mois et on trouve pas un milliard pour
le RSA pour les plus pauvres là en 15
jours on trouve 400 milliards pour les
banques donc les plus riches et l'ironie
veut que ça soit la même lo finance
pratiquement à deux articles d'écart o
on a voté le RSA et le soutien le
soutien au financement et et cette
dissonance elle est toujours là c'est
c'est pas la seule raison pour laquelle
il y a une défiance d' vie des élites
mais je pense que ça y a largement
contribué les gens ont bien compris que
quand ça n'allait pas on appelait le 20e
de cavalerie d'État la rescous quand
c'est effectivement les banques donc les
riches et les puissants c'est quoi c'est
privatisation des des gains et
socialisation des pertes ouis c'est oui
des pertes et des gains ou du risque en
tout cas enfin socialisation du risque
quand on gagne c'est pour nous quand
vous perdez c'est voilà et c'est vrai
qu' quand on quand on se retourne il y a
euah
personne n été en prison après cette
crise en Islande il y en a qui ét mais
mais Dick Dick F patron de Lesman je
crois qu'il est tou dans son manoir je
sais plus où il est en Floride ou
ailleurs il peut-être qu'il rumine un
peu sur ce qui aurait pu se passer
cétait ça avait mieux fini mais voilà
enfin comment ça se fait que ils ont pas
été en tle
c'est une très bonne question j'ai pas
la réponse ils ont des compromates sur
chacun ilsent tous par la Barb non je je
sais pas après il y a pe une question
juridique ou bah c'était pas eux c'était
pas eux c'était la société je sais pas
mais c'est responsable mais pas coupable
peut-être quand Christine la garde à
l'époque elle dit elle déclare ce n'est
pas un crack
c'est c'est quoi c'est c'est un manque
de perception c'est c'est une
déconnexion c'est la comm communication
damage c'est la communicationon
je me souv pas qu'elle avait dit ça le
le le fait est que sur
quand on voit com pour avoir beaucoup
travaillé parce qu' l'époque ch
américain là comment il s'appelle Paul
pas Paul non l'autre
greenPan greenPan quand greenPan merci
quand greenPan dit nos institutions
financières sont forte ou c'est quoi
c'est c'est c'est de pas créer la
panique encore plus il y a eu plusieurs
phases dans cette c'est sûr que il y a
eu un moment très étonnant entre entre
en gros après le crack d'Inter inter on
parlait tout à l'heure 2001 2002 chute
de World Trade du World Trade Center
crack internet on a eu une période où
effectivement les taux d'intérêts ont
baissé et où l'économie mondiale a
plutôt bien fonctionné et c'était un
moment un peu fou
il faut il faut se rappeler qu'une
banque comme Deutsche Bank qui est
toujours là aujourd'hui qui est toujours
aussi en en qui va un peu mie auourd'hui
va peu mieux va un peu mieux ils ont ils
ont un nouveau paton ils étent très
malade avant non ah bah oui et
précisément pour le point que j'allais
mentionner c'est une banque en short qui
qui qui qui disait en en 2000 nous on
vise 20 à 25 % de Roe c'estàdire de
rendement sur nos capitaux il y a
personne de civilisé c'est qu'on peut
gagner sur une banque 20 ou 25 % de re
ça n'existe pas sauf à prendre des
risques fous mais c'était ça
l'atmosphère des années 2001 2002 2003
c'est une atmosphère il faut se rappeler
le le le prier semestre 2007
le prer semestre 2007 estce que vous
est-ce que vous vous rappelez quelle
était la grande opération financière qui
agitait toute la planète
ça commence par un e par un a ABN Amro
exact ABN Amro la première banque des
Pays-Bas la première banque des Pays-Bas
fait l'objet d'une offre publique
d'achat par barkle qui est première
banque britannique à l'époque ça paraît
complètement évident que grandes banques
tout ça tout ça se rapproche pour une
raison très simple parce que l'argent
était gratuit les les les pas gratuit en
en tout cas très bon marché et pourquoi
parce que les pays occidentaux avaient
un rating très élevé et donc les grandes
banques occidentales emprunté chez elles
pas cher acheter d'autres banques et
grâce à leur argent pas cher pouvait
financer pas cher des banques et donc on
envoyait l'argent partout sur la planète
vous achetez une petite banque dans un
pays des Balcans une petite banque en
Asie centrale à partir de d'un pays
européen
vous aviez immédiatement ce qu'on appel
les synergies financières avec c'est
beau c'est beau le vocabulaire
extraordinaire qu exactement j'eniit du
PowerPoint et et donc et donc début 2007
vous avez ABN Amro donc très grande
banque qui fait l'objet d'une attaque de
barkleay et d'une contre-attaque et
c'est c'est là que c'est assez fou par
un consortium de trois banque Fortis qui
a été racheté après par BNP paribba euh
RBS qui a été nationalisé par pour la
sauver par le Trésor britannique et
sentender qui a repris un morceau qu' l'
revendu et qui c'est ça espagnol
espagnol pardon donc c trois banques et
en fait on ont voulu découper une banque
qui qui al ça ça paraît sur le papier
très simple mais en réalité je crois que
c'est Baudoin pro qui était le patron de
BNP paribba à l'époque qui avait dire
c'est comme découper au chalumeau une
Formule 1 dans la dans la ligne droite
d'un Grand Prix enfin on sait pas mais à
l'époque ce qui est extraordinaire c'est
que
aucun régulateur n'a dit mais on peut
pas faire ça pourquoi parce que le
maître mot c'était l'effet de levier
c'était le ROE et et le r donc le
rendement sur capitaux évidemment il est
accéléré l'effet de l vie c'est quand je
m'endettete pour faire une opération je
suis désolé si je suis trop technique
vous m'arrêtez et donc l'idée c'était de
ça il faut être de plus en plus gros
sendetter de plus en plus et faire du
levier c'était ça Lee pardon et manger
tout le monde oui et en fait ce qui est
extraordinaire c'est que vous aviez
barkleay et RBS qui était la première et
la deuxième banque britannique en 2007
qui qui attaqué ABN Amro et à aucun
moment le régulateur britannique ne
s'est élev en disant mais attendez vous
pouvez pas faire ça vous avez pas vous
n'avez pas de capitaux c'est qu'en fait
on s'est rendu compte que le le bilan de
Barles ou RBS cétait du flan oui et
personne n'a rien dit et on était là et
les journaux admiraient et on disait oui
regarde il a fait une c'était ça
l'atmosphère on a on a changé de monde
en 2007 le prer semestre c'était ça le
deuxème semestre subprime et 2008 Lesman
c'est c'est cette espèce de revirement
et donc il y a eu des déclarations un
certain nombre de dirigeants l'idée le
subpre caractérise bien ça l'idée et
pour moi c'est pour le coup c'est pas un
accident juste juste un truc la
déclaration exacte de Christine Lagarde
je lis un papier de 2007 de l'Obs c'est
pour pour elle il s'agit d'un ajustement
d'une correction financière certes
brutal mais prévisible en 2007 c'est
quand même le consensus c'était pas
obligé que ça finisse avec la feuille de
l' vanan BRS enfin il y a aussi une
série de en 2007 crise du subprime c'est
ça ressemble une crise comme les autres
c'est ce que je vous disais quand on a
fait le coque en 2008 ça ressemble à une
crise comme les autres comme la B
internet ça ressemble à une crise comme
les autres pour ceux qui n'ont pas les
mains dans le camboui et qui pil
elle était ministre des Finances depuis
15 jours quand quand on aussi voilà et
elle fait quoi là déjà en ce moment elle
est où elle est présidente de la Banque
centrale européenne d'accord et et vous
avez vu le film The Big short oui bien
sûr c'était pas prévisible pour ceux qui
ne connaissaient pas les si c'est c'est
comme toujours y a toujours il y en a un
qui qui s'est fait un peu ou pas pas
qu'un d'ailleurs il y en a quelquesuns
euh non bien sûr qu'il y a des gens il y
a des banques qui étaient des deux côtés
de l'équation enfin on a quand mêmee
d'habitude plus ou moins euh encore une
fois j'aime pas jeter l' propre sur
l'ensemble d'une profession mais c'est
vrai qu'il y a des gens
le Big SH on témoigne le l'autre film
auquel je suis très attaché qui est
Inside Job qui est qui est un peu alors
le Big short c'est vraiment sur ceux qui
ont à partir du livre de Michael Lewis
ceux qui ont vraiment vu que le le le
système du subprime je sais pas si tout
qu' y avait des des lunettes au rayon X
pour voir tout ce qui était r mais pasil
faut rappeler bien sû on a le temps le
le subprime en fait le le système et
c'est c'est là qu'on rentre dans le dans
le défaut de conception originale et là
il faut presque remonter à 1970 et au
modèle néolibéral le
dans le modèle dans le modèle tel qui
s'est met en place entre 1970 et 1990
il y a l'idée que les marchés savent et
et pour et pour moi c'est la bascule
elle s'opère entre 70 et 71 il y a deux
dates très importantes le 15 août 1971
et le 13 septembre 1970 et c'est
vraiment des dates je je veux pas avoir
l'air trop pédent ou anal comme disent
des Anglais
15 août 1971 Richard Nixon prend par
surprise à terre entière en disant on
arrête la la convertibilité en hors du
dollar temporairement ça fait combien 50
ans que ça ça fait 53 ans que le
temporaire dure et pourquoi il fait ça
parce que le système qui avait été mis
en place en 1945 donc après la guerre on
reconstruit et on reconstruit c'est
c'est les fameux accords de Bretton wood
sur le plan économique et monétaire les
accords de Breton Wood c'est deux choses
c'est ce qui est devenu la Banque
mondiale d'un côté dont l'objectif était
de financer la reconstruction il y et de
contrer le communisme oui ENF surtout en
44 45 c'était vraiment financé la
reconstruc d'ailleurs le premier prêt de
la Banque mondiale était à la France
alors aujourd'hui ça ça paraît très
baroque mais à l'époque c'était la
France et le FMI qui est le policier du
système international parce que c'est un
système c'estàdire vous avez l'or le
dollar est convertible en or et on va
faire en sorte que les autres monnaies
soient convertibles en dollars donc vous
avez un système qui est organisé avec un
policier et le FMI son job c'est de
vérifier que les balances des paiements
des pays ne divergent pas trop pour
qu'il y ait pas des déséquilibres et que
le système reste à peu près homogène
évidemment tout ça et ça a été bien
démontré par un certain nombre
d'économistes don le Belge Robert tri ne
pouvait pas tenir si les frontières
étaient ouvertes parce que les dollars
sont sortis ça a été les les eurob bonds
ça a été la guerre du Vietnam y y a et
en fait des gens comme celui qui a rendu
sa poul c'est le général de Gaulle qui a
dit bah moi les dollars je veux pas de
dollars je veux de l'or donc a dit je
renvoie mes dollars il n pas le seul les
Allemands fait pareil il y a un certain
nombre de gens qui ont dit bah je je
préfère garder mon or et donc les
réserves américaines banque centrale
voilà et donc les réserves américaines
qui représentaient plus de la moitié des
réserves mondiales en 1945 donc donc
tout le monde dit bah c'est super bien
en 1970
j'ai plus le chiffre exact en fait
c'était de l'ordre de 10 ou 15 % et ça
fondait donc Nixon dit c'est pas
possible j'arrête c'est pour ça que
maintenant fortnoox il ne publient plus
leur réservve ah je sais pas alors en
plus c'est pas forcément les c'est pas
il faut pas non plus imaginer que les
les barres d'or passent d'un continent à
l'autre il y a dans les dans les coffres
il a une étiquette ça c'est t appartient
à la France et T appartient et cetera
bon oua ça c'est du folklore mais ça ça
c'est Fouré au tanksten
par exemple et non mais mais ce qui est
intéressant avec cette bascule du 15
août 71 c'est qu'il prend tout le monde
par surprise et et on passe d'un système
organisé encore une fois avec l'or le
dollar les autres monnaies un policier
et des ajustement régulierers à un
système où c'est le marché qui dit la
valeur non seulement sur les devises
mais petit à petit chez tout le monde
c'estàd qu'à partir du 15 aoû 71 et
aujourd'hui si je vous dis combien vaut
1 € vous allez me dire ça vaut tant de
dollars super un dollar ça vaut
combienah ça vaut tant d'euros
d'ailleurs ça change tous les jours ça
vaut combien gr à l'époque l'on d'or
vait 35 dollars c'est ce qui était le
prix fixe aujourd'hui elle vaut 2000
dollars une 11 de 3 pardon une 11 de 3
c'est ça on dit UNE 11 2 3 non je sais
pas ça fait combien de Gramm
c'est 045 GELOSE 11 non 31 33 g 31 une
11 d'or c'est pardon oui c'est
oui c'est c'est de de 30 ou 35 g oui oui
et et donc le donc première conséquence
de de la suspension la convertibilité en
or on sort d'un système organisé
deuxième conséquence on on délègue au
marché le soin de fixer les valeurs et
de er depuis on est pas sorti parce que
effectivement et et aujourd'hui vous
interrogez n'importe qui tout le monde
pense que tout est fixé sur des marchés
on revient à la question de la
spéculation et cetera et mais c'est
devenu un système de fait un système
mondial et troisème conséquence qu'on
voit encore aujourd'hui c'est que
finalement on rentre dans l'air de ce
qu'on appelle la Fiat monnaie avant vous
aviez une référence à l'or donc vous dit
bah ok j'ai un stock d'or quelque part
et là brusquement bah vous faites
confiance à votre banque centrale
c'estàd que l'euro aujourd'hui ou ou le
dollar ou la LEF sterling ou le yen y a
il y a pas d'or il y a un peu d'or mais
mais mais mais c'est une fraction infime
de la contrepartie de la masse monétaire
et donc cette masse monétaire elle n'a
de valeur que parce que vous avez
confiance dans le système alors un peu
parce queelle a force de loi mais elle
vous avez confiance dans le système et
donc tant que la banque centrale a la
confiance de ses clients bah elle peut
créer de la monnaie on l'a vu on a
inventé le trillionss on a inventé le
CAD willlions ENF voilà tant tant qu'on
a confiance le mur il est touché quand
on a plus confiance pour l'instant
pourquoi drillions le billions c'est
combien de milliards alors le le
trillion c'est 1000 milliards c'était
l'unité de base alors au moment de au
moment de la crise de 2000 8 c'était 400
milliards le plan français le plan
Paulson qui était équivalent du plan
français pour les ÉtatsUnis c'était 700
milliards
quand on se rappelle le covid réaction
12000 milliards donc on est pas ou on
rajoute des zéos à chaque fois donc bon
je je pas tirer des traits à l'infini
mais voilà mais ça sans Nixon c'était
pas possible il fallait couper le couper
le lien donc on a basculé de système le
15 A 71 le système macro change et le 13
septembre 70
c'est la c'est pour le coup c'est c'est
connecté parce que c'est l'ensemble qui
fait système c'est le fameux article de
Milton Freedman dans le New York Times
donc à l'époque le débat aux États-Unis
c'était de savoir si General Motors donc
General Motors qui était à l'époque la
première entreprise américaine on disait
il y avait il y avait un proverbe
américain qui disait ce qui est bon pour
generalér Motors est bon pour l'Amérique
et ce qui est bon pour l'Amérique est
bon pour generalér Motors bon et General
Motors se pose la question d'introduire
dans sa gouvernance donc son conseil
d'administration trois représentants du
public interest
public pardon de l'intérêt public
l'intér public ce qu'on appellerait des
parties prenant aujourd'hui enfin des
gens représentant l'intérêt général et
donc il y a un vrai débat aux États-Unis
pour si c'est une bonne idée parce que
si Gal Motors fait ça bah c'est sûr que
d'autres vont suivre et Milton Friedman
prend la plume dans le New York Times
c'est fait un article retentissant dans
lequel il dit c'est la phrase qui est
devenue très célèbre depuis the social
purpose of business iscree profit but in
French but in French l'objet social de
l'entreprise est de maximiser ou
d'accroître ses profits c'est-à-dire
qu'il pose très clairement l'idée que
l'objet la fin en soi de l'activité
économique c'est le profit la cupidité
oui après après on peut dépre empêcher
la cupidité non non pardon sur le profit
on peut débattre du bon niveau de profit
qui est qui est une question extrêmement
difficile
mais mais ce qui est intéressant c'est
que il dit pas qu'il y a pas de public
interess d'ailleurs il dit pas qu'il y a
pas d'intérêt public il dit l'intérêt
public c'est l'état c'est les villages
c'est les communautés et cetera mais
l'entreprise son job c'est le profit le
profit qui est une fin en soi et et et
en fait en en 6 mois on a établi les
bases de ce qui est devenu le modèle
néolibéral ce qu'on a appelé pour le
reste du monde le consensus de
Washington ce qui a été célébré la chute
du mur de Berlin et dans ce consensus
c'est pour ça je reviens à la question
sur la réglementation dans ce consensus
c'est le marché qui sait et le marché il
fonctionne s'il est pas trop réglementé
s'il y a pas trop de sable dans les
rouages c'est ce que Margaret satcher
appel touch regulation il y a une
citation que j'aime beaucoup de de mon
maître au sens propre du terme Michel ku
qui a été patron du FMI pendant 14 ans
1987 à 2000 qui m'a raconté je crois
qu'il l'a mis dans ses Mémoires je suis
plus trop sûr en tout il l'a raconté en
1989 il est avec Margaret satcher à
Londres c'était au moment de la crise de
la dette latino-américaine donc les pays
latino-américains avait beaucoup
beaucoup emprunté crise et donc on
essaie de restructurer cette dette évid
ément les banquiers qui avaient prêté
essayent de restructurer en leur faveur
ça c'est un jeu aussi vieux que
l'humanité puis les fond vos tour
l'époque ça existait pas trop encore
mais en tout cas les banquiers
s'organisent et disent bah voilà
il faut il faut pas que faut pas qu'on
souffre parce que si on souffre ça aura
des conséquences dans nos pays parce que
si la banque perd de l'argent ben je
pourrais pas prêter enfin bref tous les
arguments traditionnels et donc Michel
Canu se retrouve avec Margaret satur à
Londres avec les banquiers et
et donc commence à dire au banquier ok
ils ont beaucoup emprunté mais enfin
vous leur avez beaucoup prêté ENF
vousêes la responsabilité elle est un
peu partagée c'est un peu comme le
dealer qui qui qui fait un Chrome vous
savez ce que c'est un chrome un crédit
oui bah c'est c'est c'est un peu le même
principe c'est tu veux de la dette je
j'en ai justement pour toi je te rends
adcte
alors je sais pas si c'est et ensuite je
te saigne je sais pas si on peut aller
jusqu'à jusqu'à cette image qui est
probablement un peu un peu raide mais en
tout en tout état de cause Michel Canu
pose la bonne question je dire c'est
c'est pas il y a pas des les méchants
emprunteurs et les gentil banquiers il y
a il y a deux personnes qui ont fait
peut-être une erreur d'analyse une
mauvaise appréciation du risque ENF les
deux et alors il raconte que Margaret
satur se tourne vers lui en disant don't
lecture the bankers they know ne faites
pas la morale au banquier parce que
c'est c'est eux qui savent la morale le
chantage non la morale don lectur Lect
don lectur ça me fait pas la morale et
donc l'idée c'est et c'est ce qu'on
appelle light touch regulation laisser
le marché faire ils savent quand il se
planteent ça fait du mal quand même he
ben c'est c'est c'est pour ça que je dis
la crise de 2007 c'est pas un accident
ça devait arriver
l'ABN Amro pour moi c'est c'est c'est
c'est le sommet enfin qu' qu'on ait
laissé deux banques qui en réalité
n'étaient pas capitalisé le régulateur
ne dit rien et on attaque ABN Amro bah
c'était c'était le l'explosion d'un
système les agences de notation
là-dedans c'est c'est un peu c'est du
cosmétique ça arrange tout le monde
c'est pour ça que la la Chine a créé sa
propre agence de notation les agences de
notation de l'époque
alors il suffit pas de dire c'est un
c'est un serpent de merde dire je vais
créer mon agence de notationé
tout le monde oui mais on n pas crédible
parce qu'on CR une agence de notation
les agences de notation en 2008 elles
étaient crédibles ah bah là elles sont
pas passé très loin de de la
correctionnelle
de la TLE ah non de la correctionnelle
correctionnelle à coup de bâton ou une
correctionn mais c'était un moment où
c'était
c'était un moment où es ont été assez
largement mis en question
alors ét misise en question pourquoi
alors a y a plusieurs métiers notation
c'est d'ailleurs souvent la plupart de
ces prestataires de service c'est là que
c'est compliqué de gérer différents
métiers il y a un métier traditionnel
qui est celui qu'on connaît que le grand
public connaît qui est la notation des
États en particulier le triple A de la
France des états-unisiste plus tri la
France ça n'existe plus en tout cas la
notation la note de crédit des pays
souverains ça c'est métier traditionnel
et après on note en fait toutes les
obligations de toutes les entrepris
prise et cetera là où c'est là où c'est
quand je parlais correctionnel où cétait
un vrai sujet c'est que dans le subprime
pour en revenir au subpre l'idée et
c'était typiquement ce que proposait
Bern pas Berny Alan Greenspan dont on
parlait tout à l'heure c'est grâce au
marché on va répartir le risque on va le
mettre là où il est le mieux hébergé
donc ça c'était la théorie et c'est vrai
que le subprime c'est c'est en partie ce
raisonnement c'est se dire on va prêter
à des gens et donc les les les cé un
système qui est fou quand on y réfléchit
vous avvez des courtiers qui allit voir
des gens en disant vous pouvez emprunter
ça vous coûte rien la première année et
façon comme l'immobilier monte
l'immobilier monte toujours vous
rembourserai avec votre maison et puis
et puis d'ailleurs vous pouvez en
acheter 5 10F il y eu de la fraude
massive et cetera c'est une genre de
pyramide de Ponzi
bah sur une partie de une partie des
choses ce qui est terrible c'est que ça
parti encore une fois d'un bon sentiment
c'estàd que c'était une décision
américaine de dire il faut faciliter
l'accès à la propriété mais là où la
finance a dérapé c'est qu'elle en a fait
un dérapage massif et et pervers et et
que les agences de notation pour une
partie de leur métier ont contribué à ça
puisque les en fait laière don ça se
passait vous êtes un courtier vous allez
voir je viens vous voir en disant bah
voilà vous ce qu'on appelle vous n'avez
pas d'enfant vous enfin vous n'avez pas
d'actif vous n'avez rien mais vous
pouvez acheter une maison et voilà vous
signez là moi je vous trouve une banque
la banque vous montre le truc donc vous
vous vous empruntez auprès d'une banque
vous pensez à la française que vous avez
emprunté après de la banque X mais en
fait la banque X elle veut pas du tout
garder votre prêt donc elle va le donner
à quelqu'un qui va faire ce qu'on
appelle une titrisation donc elle va
elle va additionner des prêts elle va
elle va dire voilà je mets 10000 prêt
donc ça fait un milliard de dollars ou
je sais pas combien et elle va sortir ce
prêt de son bilance c'est plus elle qui
va les porter elle va les confier à des
gens qui vont les vendre et qui vont les
vendre à des fonds de pension suédois
qui qui vont les vendre à des villages
allemands qui vont les vendre à des
banques japonaises la théorie c'est on
va le donner à ceux qui savent porter le
risque on a vu à qui on l'avait vendu
et donc les notation pour revenir à
votre question là là où elles ont elles
ont contribuer à ce système vous dites
on a vu à qui on les a vendus
non on a vendu ça à des gens qui étaient
pas capables de gérer le risque la
théorie c'était dire on va on va mettre
le risque au bon endroit et en fait on
l'a vendu à des gens qui il y a quand
même toute une série de scandal dans
certain nombre de pays on a vendu des
trucs l'lande un petit peu non alors
l'Islande c'est encore autre chose c'est
les banques islandaises qui qui ont qui
ont voulu jouer la grenouille plus
grosse que le buuf donc elles ont gonflé
leur bilan elles ont participé à cet eff
mais je finis sur le sub prime pour la
notation
notation en fait c'est ce paquet de 1
milliard de crédits on a dit bah voilà
il y a un milliard de crédit mais
statistiquement ils vont pas tous faire
défaut on va les trancher donc on va on
va faire des des catégories de risque et
euh c'est là qu'on revient la théorie on
va vendre ça à ceux qui savent le mieux
et donc on va dire bah voilà on va faire
une tranche à 100 millions qui sont les
plus risqués puis 200 millions puis 500
millions et cetera et les notation ont
mis une note sur tout ça les plus risqué
qui rapporte le bah le plus évidemment
et donc on a vendu ça en disant bah oui
c'est risqué mais quand même il y a un
bon rating et et donc d'une certaine
manière tout le monde a mis les doigts
dans la confiture dans ce dans ce truc
et et c'est vrai que ça a explosé
c'était affreux c'était vraiment affreux
ça eu pour conséquence de faire gonfler
la dette de tout le monde de tous les
états oui bien sûr ensuite derrière on
va reparler de zob short parce qu'il y a
des trucs sympa quand même dans ce film
donc ça fait flamber la dette de
beaucoup d'État
bah la dette française est passée j'ai
plus exactement les chiffres mais enfin
c'est le moment on est passé on devit
être audessus autour de 65 70 % de d'un
ratio de dette sur produit national brut
à plus de 90 % à ce momentl vous avez
jamais fait le petit jeu de con
convertir la dette de la France en baril
de pétrole
non
vous comprenez en fait le parallèle
convertir de la dette avec des
ressources tangible oui on revient on
revient au fait que ça devient une
espèce d'illusion c'est ce qu'on appelit
l'argent magique pendant le covid à un
moment donné ce qui était terrible si
vous vous souvenez
Nicolas Sarkozi avait dit le triple A
c'est notre trésor national
non mais rappelez-vous un peu comme l'or
qu' l' vendu non non non mais
rappelez-vous le le trésor national il
faut absolument qu'on préserve notre
triple A vous avez suivi l'affaire de la
vente d'or par Nicolas Sarkozi non
c'était magnifique non mais je finis sur
le triple A donc on perd notre triple A
on a dit à tous les Français le aple a
si on le perd c'est la catastrophe et en
fait les taux d'intérêt ont continué à
baisser et pendant toutes les années
2010 on a payé moins cher qu'on avait un
triple A donc c'est compliqué de manière
pédagogique d'expliquer à des gens
attendez on a perdu notre trésor mais en
fait c'est quand même moins cher vous
avez dit que çaait être la catastrophe
mais quand même non c'est pas la
catastrophe quand il y a les taux qui
remontent comment on fait pour soutenir
et bah c'est la question à laquelle on
est confronté aujourd'hui et et pour moi
on est à un moment très très important
en fait on parla de Paul walkker tout à
l'heure depuis 1980 jusqu'à aujourd'hui
on a oublié l'inflation et les taux avec
des haut desbas ont globalement suivi
une pente descendante toi quand tu étais
jeune c'était 15 % non ouais et et on
est tombé à 1 % enfin quand mes parents
s'endettai pour acheter un appartement
dans les années 70 c'était 14 15 16 % et
ceux qui se sont endettés il y a 2 3 ans
ils ont sendettés à 1 ou 1.5 %. donc
c'est ça toujours dans le même sens et
quand il y avait un problème on savait
que les banques centrales intervenit
pour faire le le backstop comme on dit
en anglais pour arrêter le le le
problème et là aujourd'hui on arrive à
un moment où les banques centrales nous
disent moi j'arrête là j'arrête de de de
faire le le stop les taux ont remonté
ils vont probablement re baisser un peu
mais ils re baisseront pas à 1 % donc
ils vont rester plus élevés et on a on a
renouvé de l'inflation et donc on se
retrouve avec des gens qui ont jamais
connu ça et d' je vais parler des des
exemples de banques qui sont pris la
porte dans la figure qui on qui ont fait
faillite en 15 jours et cetera parce que
parce que les gens avaient pas connu ça
donc ils vont arriver ça ils ont pas
d'expérience c'est aussi simple que ça
quand tu vois la masse monétaire gonflé
gonfl gonflé gonflé et que tu vois de
l'autre côté une rarfaction des
ressources par exemple le cuivre
l'uranium
il faut réouvrir des mines et puis la la
densité de M de de de minéraux peut
ressortir c'est moins est-ce que il y a
pas une décorrélation entre la politique
des banques centrales et la réalité que
la terre peut nous offrir est-ce qu'on n
pas confié les clés de l'asile au fou
non je crois pas est-ce que la le bon
sens paysan euh
ça existe pas dans les banques centrales
je c je crois pas enfin j' j'irais pas
dire qu'elles sont irréprochable non euh
quand on se retourne heureusement qu'on
les a eu je ve c'est ça non mais je suis
d'accord ig
fa non mais je reviens à au 15 71 au 15
71 on a accepté que la monnaie était
décorrélée d'une ressources qui étaaient
lors et de de quelque chose de tangible
aujourd'hui la monnaie elle est
représentative d'une certaine forme de
richesse mais elle a pas elle a pas de
lien immédiat entre les ressources
naturel le pétrole le cuivre l'énergie
solaire ou que sais-je encore c'est
c'est c'est pour ça on est rentré dans
une analyse très différente des politiqu
monétaire de la masse monétaire et
cetera on est dans la Fiat monie c'est
un exercice différent
donc si je veux convertir la dette
française en baril de pétrole c'est
inintéressant possible c'est ça en tout
cas je me suis pas posé la question je
réfléchirai après notre échange ça fait
combien d'années de consommation de
pétrole de la France ça te parle pas la
dette française convertie par ça fait
combien une trentaine d'années à V 3000
milliards d'euros et on doit faire 100
milliards d'euros de de pétrole par an
en ordre de grandeur mais
ça fait beaucoup non ouai mais enfin
limite on peut
comment tuexpliqu l'inflation qui on
comparer au patrimoine de la France je y
a plein de métriques c'est celui qu'on a
pas encore vendu non non mais le
patrimoine des individus enfin il y a
des tas le patrimoine immobilier la
jeocond ENF j'en sais rien c'est pas
c'est les métriques sont pas très
simples c'est pas mais je pense que
encore une fois on revient au point de
départ qui est la la Fiat monnaie dans
un système où on est plus assis sur du
tangible on est assis sur la confiance
qu'est-ce qui se passe quand la
confiance se brise ahah ça all est
demandé aux Argentins est demandé aux
Allemands de 1920 ça il y a plein
d'exemples ça se finit très très mal
chacun sait que la confiance elle peut
se perdre en quelques secondes et qu'on
met des années à la reconstruire donc
c'est ça qui est qui est très très
important et et c'est ça pour revenir
dans les banques centrales qui est au
cœur de leur métier c'est ça ça
si elles perdent leur confiance elle
meurent et si elle meurt qu'est-ce qui
se passe ah bah là c'est le chaos
l'histoire l'histoire montre que ça se
finit en général assez mal quand le
volume est très important c'est un un
plus grand chaos quand le volume de le
volume de dette ou le volume de
confiance explose
quand les gens perdent la confiance dans
leur banque centrale dans leur monnaie
ça se matérialise comment c'est un bank
run les gens se précipitent comment ça
c'est la ris encore une fois j'ai pas
j'ai pas cette expérience en direct et
forth heureusement c'est assez rare en
tout cas dans les grandes économies
sophistiqué priori c'est pas c'est pas
quelque chose auquel j'espère qu'on sera
pas confronté de notre vivant mais c'est
vrai quand on reprend l'exemple de 2008
qui est un exemple intéressant euh
on se retrouve donc faillite de Lesman
BRS plan de soutien à l'économie et euh
Nicolas Sarkozi qui prend un peu tout le
monde par surprise dans le dans son
discours à Toulon et qui dit euh
en gros tous les dépôts sont garantis
c'est pas ça non non c'est il y a sapin
qui a fait le la loi sur la garantie des
dép pe importe cétait c'était pas le
sujet mais euh c'est garanti par l'État
par la Banque centrale non c'est garanti
par un fond de garantie dans lequel il y
avait 1 milliard et demi d'euros avec un
effet de levier ou pas d'effet de levier
non non mais il y avait il y avait 1
milliard et demi d'euros à l'époque à
peu près dans le dans le fond de
garantie alors que les dépôts des
grandes banques c'était plusieurs
milliers de milliards donc on on était
pas dans mais il fallait rassurer les
gens donc on était dans la confiance
mais c'est vrai que ATT pardon je finis
non non non non c'est je je finis parce
que c'est normalement j'avais un job s
directeur financier crédcole qui la
première banque française 35 % du
financement de l'économie donc on avait
une responsabilité pour le coup je
voulais pas que ça pète ça c'est clair
et et et donc c'est vrai qu'on a on a
immédiatement mis en place des systèmes
est-ce que les gens retirent plus
d'argent des distributeurs est-ce qu'ils
vont retirer plus et ca on a eu des
comportements c'estz resté marginal mais
très intéressant où des gens allaient
dans leur banque en disant je veux
retirer le maximum 50000 € et qu'est-ce
que vous en faites je les mets dans un
coffre à la banque il m dit mais
attendez mais parce que en fait je me
souv il y avait une émission capitale
qui avait été très intéressante à
l'époque en fait le l'économie bancaire
c'est quelque chose d'assez compliqué on
passe le bonjour à Emmanuel chin par
exemple et non mais c'est c'est un
métier compliqué quand quand vous
interrogez autour de vous et c'était
quelque chose que je faisais beaucoup à
l'époque les gens comprennent pas très
bien en fait comment ça fonctionne et
après tout on peut vivre sans très bien
comprendre comment fonctionne une banque
et capital avit fait une émission où je
me souviens c'était un un mur
kinésithérapeute de Strasbourg qui
arrivit à la caisse départ de Strasbourg
déposer ses chèqus de la semaine et
après capital suivait euh qu'est-ce que
deviennent ses chèqus enfin en gros
c'est crédité sur ton compte il montrait
qu'en fait quand on mettait de l'argent
à la banque cet argent il était recyclé
alors quefin il était recyclé il était
prêté enfin je veux dire l'argent du du
maassœur kéapeut servez après apprprêter
si vous voulez achetez un appartement
enfin voilà c'est c'est c'est le flux
monétaire et que quand vous posez la
question aux gens à l'époque les gens
avaient cette vision un peu de la banque
de luckyc c'est euh bah je vais au
guichet et puis je mets mon argent le
gars Oure son coffre mais l'argent ferme
donne à reçu et s'en va il pense que son
argent bouge pas c'est très étonnant
vous avez une vision euh très et et on
avait très peur à ce moment-là que les
gens se disent là mais ça va craquer
donc je retire mon argent et ça ne s'est
pas passé parce que parce que le système
le système a tenu et que la parole
publique a tenu on peut ironiser tout ce
qu'on veut les gens ont cru ça s'est
très bien passé il y a pas eu de craque
à ce moment-là de même 3 3 ans plus tard
en 2012 ou 4 ans plus tard en 2012 quand
Mario dragi président de la Banque
centrale européenne quand av des
attaques très très fortes sur l'euro a
dit des attaques de qui pardon des
attaques de qui non mais les monnaaies
la monnaie européne éta attaqué
notamment les pays du Sud à part les
marchés qui pensaient que le système
était pas tenable parce queeectivement
il y avait des trop grands écarts entre
l'Italie l'Espagne la franceché bah
c'est vous et moi c'est tout le monde
c'est les marchés c'est votre assureur
vie c'est le livra c'est la trésorerie
de la Société générale c'est tout ce que
vous voulez les marchés c'est c'est
c'est c'est à la fois quelque chose de
très et la contre-attaque parce que non
non mais je pas été discipliné moi quand
on mtaque pas discié vous m'interrompez
tout le temps non non non pas encore
j'essaie en fait de non mais c'est des
histoires compliquées donc je je je
juste finir sur la banque centrale et
Mario drag pour dire que la confiance
c'est un sujet très important qu'est-ce
qui s'est passé en 2012 en 2012 on avait
c'était horrible on avait des attaques
sur ce qu'on appelait les PIGS je sais
pas si vous vous souvenez c'est c'est P
c'était Portugal Irlande Grèce oui bien
sûr ça veut dire cochon en anglais et
c'était un acronyme que que les gens
utilisaient pour parler des pays du sud
de l'Europe et donc il y avait un une
attaque en disant c'est l'euro n'est pas
tenable ils vont finir par sortir ça ça
ne marche pas et donc euh il y avait une
prime sur ces pays de sortie de l'euro
donc les gens payaient beaucoup plus
cher leurs emprunts parce qu'on pensait
qu'ils avent sortir de l'euro et à ce
momentlà revenait à la lire à la DRAC
mais c'était parti en ville et Mario
Dragui par la seule force de son verbe
c'est un cas extrêmement intéressant
c'est que les gens avaient confiance
dans une conférence de presse à l'été
2012 a dit la banque centrale fera tout
tout ce qu'il faut pour maintenir l'euro
c'était pas écrit dans son discours il
dit croyez-moi ça sera suffisant et ben
immédiatement les gens dit ok la banque
centrale je m'aligne
donc c'est ça qu'il faut préserver et
c'est ça que tous les banquiers centraux
ont à cœur de préserver c'est cette
confiance le fait que leurs paroles soi
écouté c'est ça qui est très très
important c'est un peu comme madof qui
était un beau parleur avec des beaux
costards et qui avait le le verbe cisel
bah la différence c'est que madof quand
on ouvrait sa porte il y avait rien
derrière quand on ouvre la porte de la
BC de rés il y a quand même quelque
chose derrière il y a quoi on sait ce
qu'il y a derrière il y a derrière la
BCE bah il y a les économies européennes
et la décision politique de combien
d'états européens à l'origine de créer
une banque centrale de mettre en commun
le réserve d'or c'est pas grand-chose le
réserve de devise et leur action sur les
marchés et et la loi dit que vous pouvez
libérer toutes vos dettes en euros ça ça
tant que les gens y croient et pour
l'instant ça marche très bien je suis
pas inquiet du tout comment vous
expliquez l'inflation alors l'inflation
c'est des su moi je suis pas économiste
donc donc ça il y a des tas de bouquins
qui ont été écrits là-dessus c'est des
c'est des sujets je vous renvoie
notamment au travaux récents de
d'Olivier Blanchard a qui j'ai beaucoup
travaillé qui était l'économiste en chef
du du FMI à Washington et de Ben
bernanky
le prix Nobel qui était qui é la banque
centrale
l'inflation il y a toute une série de
causes qui peuvent se superposer ou se
succéder euh
vous avez l'inflation pour le coup très
traditionnelle celle laquelle vous avez
fait référence qui a été très bien
théorisée par M John Friedman qui est
monétaire plus vous créez d'argent pour
la même quantité de biens bah les gens
ont plus d'argent donc ils payent plus
cher les biens et donc il y a de
l'inflation vous avez l'inflation qu'on
a expérimenté et c'est là qu'on a vu les
différences entre l'Europe et les
États-Unis d'ailleurs sur l'inflation
aux États-Unis il y a eu beaucoup
d'argent distribué euh les gens ont tous
reçu moi j'habité aux États-Unis j'ai
reçu un chèque comme les tous les
Américains on reçoivent des CHS on a
reçu des chèqus pendant le covid que les
gens ont finit par dépenser donc ça ça a
alimenté la machine américaine qui croit
beaucoup plus vite que la machine
européenne et donc il y a une partie de
l'inflation qui est née de ce surcroix
de de demande vous avez un pardon d'être
un peu technique vous avez aussi un choc
d'offre quand
on a la crise de de des chaînes des
chaînes de valeur enfin bah les les
produits arrivent pas donc les rares
produits qui arrivent on est prêt à les
payer plus cher on peut avoir des
facteur d'offre il il y a toute une
série de facteurs euh ce qui est très
intéressant et pour le coup j'ai pas
d'avis sur la question je mais je je je
ça m'intéressera de comprendre on a vu
aux États-Unis c'est très c'est assez
atypique euh les les banquiers centraux
pour pour casser l'inflation ont repris
la méthode Volker ont augmenté les taux
et tout le monde attendait que cette
hausse des taux fasse rentrer l'économie
en récession tout le monde attendait une
récession aux États-Unis en 2023 les
États-Unis j'ai plus le chiffre exact
c'est sorti il y a quelques jours ce
sont après 3 % de croissance et
l'inflation a baissé alors là c'était
pas dans les livres donc qu'est-ce qui
s'est passé je sais pas peti guerre avec
l'Ukraine pardon une petite guerre avec
l'Ukraine bah çait plutôt jouer ça
aurait plutôt dû jouer dans le sens de
l'inflation non non ce qui est
intéressant c'est que les États-Unis ont
réussi à à maintenir la première
croissance des pays occidentaux et à
faire baisser leur inflation
donc c'est pas un phénomène qui qui est
qui est décrit une fois pour toutes et
qui sera reproduit à l'identique
intervalle régulier non je pense que
c'est c'est un phénomène qui reste assez
complexe et qui va demander encore pas
mal de temps de de travail académique V
confiance dans l'euro est-ce que leurou
a un avenir ah oui alors j'ai j'ai une
confiance à la fois euh
émotionnel euh ce qui est c'est
peut-être mon côté mes68 et pas mon côté
versaill euh
au sens où moi je suis alsacien
personne n'est parfait
alors là
j'adore les Alsaciens quand on leur dit
ça et et euh et j'ai j'ai un grand-père
qui m'a toujours dit alors que alors
qu'on avait quelques raisons de penser
qu'on voilà on aurait pu avoir quelques
différents avec nos voisins allemands
m'a toujours dit euh Bertrand le rein
n'est pas une frontière le rein c'est un
passage le rein c'est une civilisation
et donc il faut faire l'Europe et ça je
je l'entends j'avais 7 ans 8 ans 10 ans
il m'a répété ça il m'a répété ça et je
crois qu'il avait profondément raison et
et et faire l'Europe ça passe par un
certain nombre de de de choses comme
cette monnaie unique elle était pas
rationnelle
quand j'étais étudiant Lenard on faisait
des copies pour expliquer pourquoi
c'était compliqué de faire l'euro et
cetera parce que c'est vrai que
on contrastait le le cas de l'Euro avec
le cas du dollar le marché américain
évidemment il est unique les gens
bougent moins qu'on ne le croit
d'ailleurs aujourd'hui enfin en tout cas
il a il y avait une fluidité des
facteurs comme on dit pour parler de
manière un peu pédante en Europe bah les
gens parlent pas la même langue déjà
donc l'idée que si un déséquilibre il se
résorbera avec les Allemands qui
déménageront au Portugal ou les
Portugais qui déménageront en Pologne à
voir ça c'est un peu passé mais pas dans
ses proportions donc c'était c'était
compliqué l'euro il y avait un acte
politique qui était dire on fait une
monnaie unique et c'est vrai que cette
monnaie unique au début ça a très bien
fonctionné et et et avec ce ce côté qui
qui a été qui a été à l'origine de la
crise de l'euro euh qui est finalement
qu'un pays comme la Grèce euh pouvait
emprunter comme l'Allemagne et que dans
l'esprit des gens qui savaient pas très
bien comment ça marchait une monnaie
unique on avait pas tellement de
précédents se sont dit bah au fond oui
c'est pas c'est comme le dollar donc
c'est pas grave la la Grèce c'est comme
le Texas et l'Allemagne c'est comme la
Californie
commou comme l'cansas ou peu importe et
et puis petit à petit c'est ce qui s'est
passé avec c'est qu'on dit mais en fait
non est-ce que ce système va tenir et
c'est ça qui a été le le cœur de la
crise de l'euro et c'est là que Mario
dragi a dit ça va tenir parce qu'on va
le faire tenir quoi qu'il en coûte quoi
qu'il en coûte exactement et et et je
pense qu'on c'est là en fait ayant
résisté à ce test j'ai plutôt une assez
grande confiance dans le fait qu'on
résistera à d'autres tests ça été le le
test et que on a plutôt tous intérêt à
ce que ça marche l'euro alors c'est
intéressant de voir parce qu'il y a des
débats aujourd'hui il y a des pays qui
sont pas pas dans l'euro qui sont dans
l'Union européenne qui se demande s'ils
veulent rentrer ou pas la Croatie est
rentrée il y a pas très longtemps la
Bulgarie la Roumanie se pose la question
le Danemark ne veut pas en entendre
parler mais il y a un lien relativement
fort entre la couronne danoise et l'euro
chacun avec ses raisons mais le le le la
monnaie euro pour moi c'est une avancée
fondamentale mais qui était
effectivement un geste plus politique
économique au début qui est devenu
économique aujourd'hui est-ce que c'est
pas une religion et c'est une religion
qui va laisser des des dettes à nos
enfants mais est une religion qu'est-ce
qu' écrit sur le dollar américain
et ben voilà ça veut dire quoi en
français nous croyons enfin en Dieu n
mettons notre confiance
mais on revient à 1971
on peut dire que c'est une religion je
c'est un peu excessif mais c'est vrai
que c'est un système de confiance mais
c'est un système de confiance qui est
probablement relativement économique
relativement efficace et qui marche pour
tout le monde ça marche pour tout le
monde quand on a une croissance
exponentielle
une consommation de ressources
exponentielles qu'est-ce qui se passe
qu'est-ce que vous vous m'avez dit quand
la mer se retire on voit qui est-ce qui
est à poil je pas je va pas aller jusque
là j'ai dis s maillot oui bon qui qui
s'il y a des nudices partout ou celui
qui a le plus gros fling est-ce que la
dette américaine est soutenable parce
qu'ils ont la plus grosse armée en
partie je me souviens d'une d'une
discussion que j'avais eu avec à
l'époque je sais pas ce qu'il est devenu
d'ailleurs les kit ben bernank de du
directeur financier de JP Morgan ah oui
lui il a dû avoir des petits soucis non
non justement c'est celui qui en a pas
eu et et donc il était venu me voir à
Paris en 2010
pendant pendant la crise et euh
et il me dit très clairement tu
comprends euh dans le monde the world is
notre faire le monde n'est pas euh
équitable enfin voilà tout le monde
n'est pas servi de la même manière euh
les États-Unis sont plus gros que la
France la France est plus grosse que la
Suisse et la Suisse est plus grosse que
l'Irlande qui est plus grosse que
l'Islande donc chacun joue dans dans sa
division et les Islandais les Irlandais
les Suisses et vous qui avez essayé
d'être plus gros que ce que vous nêtes
bah vous pouvez pas alors que nous on
peut donc tant pis pour vous
vous connaissez le proverbe chinois
depuis l'invention de la poudre il y a
plus d'homme fort
ouais bah c'est mais c'est vrai c'est
pour ça que le général de Gaul à mon
sens poussé pour avoir l'arme nucléaire
non non mais c'est c'est c'est les
débats des années 60 c'était je crois
que c'est giscardestin qui avait dit qui
parlait du privilège exorbitant dollar
c'est un privilège exorbitant ils
imprime la monnaie mondiale et
aujourd'hui tout le monde veut du dollar
même si on de temps en temps on dit on
veut des dollariser les Brigs veulent
changer et ceteraah les gens vont quand
même quand ils ont besoin de mettre leur
éparne quelque part ils préfèrent la
mettre en dollar qu'en rouble c'est
quand même c'est c'est assez simple
parce qu'il y a un plus gros fling voilà
the world is not fair ça fait partie des
choses auquelles la guerre économique ça
vous parle
la guerre économique ça me parle j'aime
pas le j'aime pas le mot de guerre
économique c'est c'est mon vieux fond de
sa
euh vous croyez en Dieu oui vous avez un
ami imaginaire pardon vous avez un ami
imaginaire ah ben c'est vous qui le
qualifieré d'imaginaire mais moi c'est
c'est pas imaginaire maisfon bref euh
oui ENF en tout cas la banque centrale
n'est pas l'Église dans laquelle je me
prosterne mais j'ai confiance dans la
banque centrale pour revenir à notre
conversation précédente donc je confonds
pas les différentes religions ou les
différentes croyances euh
les différents hôtels de la dévotion par
exemple
j'ai perdu fil c'est fait exprès c'est
fait exprès et ben alors alors je m'en
remets adieu
son représentant sur terre c'est trop
d'honneur
comment comment on voit euh
la guerre économique oui la guerre
économique pardon non mais c'est c'est
vrai que c'est c'est c'est pas la guerre
le paradis économique non non c'est
c'est c'est c'est intéressantf
économique c'est intéressant cette
question de guerre économique parce que
ça fait partie des des des des grands
cycles dans lequels
dans lequel on on évolue en fait je
disais on on a eu ce CYC qui est né au
début des années 70
je parlais de de Nixon et de et de
Milton Friedman qui s'est poursuivi avec
Rean SATER comme je dis souvent même
mitero a tenté de résister puis s'est
rallié donc on a eu un consensus qui
était un consensus de mondialisation
d'ouverture de frontières de libre
circulation des capitaux et l'idée
c'était euh c'était extraordinaire on
dit on va faire rentrer la Russie et la
Chine dans l'Organisation mondiale du
commerce ils vont devenir comme nous
c'était le règne du dou commerce mais
c'était pas on parlait pas de guerre
économique du tout à l'époque c'était le
mur de Berlin est tombé et c'était tout
ça va prospérer ensemble et on a
peut-être été naïf et mais mais on é
dans un cycle rappelez-vous le bouquin
d' laain la mondialisation heureuse et
cetera
non mais encore une fois c'est c'est
intéressant parce que ça ça ça montre ce
que c'est que vous avez lu les bouquins
d' la minque pardon vous avez lu ça
m'est arrivé dans les toilettes dans le
train non j'ai pas honte moi je je
dévore les livres j'en lis un par jour
donc pe on peut lire beaucoup de choses
mais ce que jeux dire c'est qu' il y
avait un état d'esprit qui était qui
était celu-là F bouche quand même non
non mais il y avait un état d'esprit qui
était celui-là qui était vraiment que la
mondialisation c'était quelque chose de
très positif et que c'est le dou
commmerce c'est montesquieux c'est c'est
c'est ce à quoi c'est ce à quoi on
croyait enfin je veux dire c'était la
peut-être croyance de l'époque en tout
cas c'était comment on dit le le le
mindset en l'état d'esprit de l'époque
pardon et et et et aujourd'hui formatage
non c'est pas un formatage mais il faut
pas t faut pas acheter le bébé a Clubin
on n pas passé de l'ombre à la lumière
de la lumière à l'ombre il s'est passé
des choses cette période a aussi cette
période non mais cette période a aussi
permis de sortir des centaines de
millions de gens de la pauvreté a permis
d'un certain nombre de choses faut faut
faut encore une fois c'est c'est jamais
ou c'est très rarement tout noir et tout
blanc en terme d'échelle de temps pardon
je je finis juste non moi je vais finir
quand je prends un dolipran quand j'ai
ouais pendant à peu près 6h j'ai plus 40
ouais c'est tout est une une échelle de
temps faire des injection de liquidité
dire que on a sorti tout le monde de la
pauvreté que c'était vachement bien que
vous voyez que maintenant les pauvres il
y en a moins que c'est c'est un petit
paracétamool en terme d'éche de temp si
la confiance se perd dans la monnaie si
on commence à se castagner tous en terme
de guerre économique pour des ressources
et ainsi de suite à votre avis le nombre
de pauvre sera plus important avant ou
après le doliprane il y a tellement de
raccourcis dans tout ce que vous venez
de dire que jeisessay ou je vais essayer
de déconstruire les raccourcis ce que je
dire c'est c'est la question des des 40
années en gros de de Friedman 1970 à la
crise financière de 2008 2009 c'est pas
juste de la liquidité et de la dette il
y a aussi eu un certain nombre de choses
qui se sont passées notamment l'entrée
de la Chine dans le commerce
international l'ouverture d'un certain
nombre de pays enfin quand même voilà
c'est pas à l'époque d'ailleurs il y a
assez peu d'injection de liquidité c'est
c'est plutôt après la crise financière
qu'on ouvre le le braquet ce qui est
intéressant c'est que cette crise
financière probablement après la crise
en Irak la guerre en irac dont je
parlais tout à l'heure ça a été les les
les premières remises en cause du modèle
occidental
et et et petit à petit ce à quoi on
abouti aujourd'hui c'est un changement
de modèle où effectivement on vous parle
de souveraineté de guerre économique de
d'approche prédatrice et on a changé de
d'état d'esprit on reparle de politique
industrielle moi je me souviens j'avais
organisé à la Banque mondiale un
événement sur la politique industrielle
en 2014 mais c'est des trucs de français
ça la politique industrielle ça inéresse
plus personne et aujourd'hui toute la
planète fait la politique industrielle
donc on a des espèces de grands
mouvements c'est pas c'est pas c'est pas
un coup je prends de l'prane et un coup
je prends de l'UPSA
c'est Lab non non mais je je pas comment
s'apppirine
ACI acé salic oui d'accord mais truc
effervescent peu importepirine voilà
mais ce que je veux dire c'est qu' on
AES mouvements la difficulté à laquelle
on est confronté aujourdhui c'est qu'on
voit bien que le cycle en 70 bah il
touche ses limites qu'on sait pas en
sortir et qu'on a du mal à faire émerger
le modèle suivant qui est le modèle qui
en thorie nous permet d'abord de alors
on on on l'a esquissé ce modèle et et
pour moi ça a été ça a été un des
moments importants de ma vie euh
en 2015
on on je ont collectivement tous les
pays de la planète ont signé trois
grands accords en 2015 alors économique
c'est l'accord sur le climat de Paris
c'est pas à niam c'est à addisabeba
Addis Abeba le partenariat pour le
développement à New York les objectifs
développement durable et euh
à Paris les accords de Paris sur le
climat c'était quoi les trois mots
bullchit qui ont servi à rien depuis
2015 c'était économie sociale et
solidaire inclusive et quoi d'autre
non alors les les les le le l'économique
en tout cas sur laquelle on s'est mis
d'accord après on peut on peut ironiser
sur les accords internationaux et cetera
et et encore une fois en est en en ayant
fait partie j'en vois à la fois les
atouts et les limites n'empêche que
c'est bien qu'à un endroit donné les
gens se mettent d'accord sur les
objectif il y a pas de policier du monde
non mais c'est quoi l'alternative c'est
un maître du monde il y en a pas donc il
faut faire avec faut faire ça avec notre
pauvre main en essayant de travailler
donc VO là on peut parler vous pouvez me
lancer sur la gouvernance mondiale je
suis le premier à dire que ça ne marche
pas et en même temps qu'il faut qu'on
fasse quelque chose avec parce qu'il y a
pas de plan B il y a pas de maître du
monde en 1945 il y avait un maître du
monde aujourd'hui il y a pas de maître
du monde parce que c'est multipolaire
oui en partie parce que c'est
multipolaire et puis parce que c'est un
monde qui n'est plus seulement un monde
d'État c'est un monde avec des ONG c'est
un monde avec la société civile c'est un
monde avec des grandes entreprise et
cetera et que il y a pas un maître du
monde comme était Truman en 1944 45 ou
Staline pour sa partie du monde ça
n'existe plus aujourd'hui et donc on on
on est on on s'est mis d'accord sur une
feuille de route alors on peut ironiser
sur cette feuille de route n'empêche
qu'elle est vraiment belle on fait de
l'humour potache ouais bien sûr non mais
je ve dire
mais en même temps je suis sensible
parce que euh c'est des gens au bout de
la chaîne c'est ça ouais puis je trouve
que la dérision c'est facile ENF je moi
je me suis coleté ce genre de chose je
me suis fait critiquer et C et je je qui
pas tout le monde qui me dit c'est des
conneries ces accords internationaux ces
photos on voit les dirigeants et cetera
oui bien sûr qu'on peut dire ça mais en
même temps c'est quoi l'alternative
c'est c'est comme je dis souvent c'est
de faire du mauvais Voltaire
l'alternative c'est de lire candide et
de conclure en disant il faut cultiver
notre jardin et de le lire au sens
strict je vais cultiver mon jardin c'est
mon bout de balcon mon truc moi je vais
m'occuper de ma famille mon village ma
boîte mon machin et cetera et le reste
du monde bah si tout le monde fait ça ça
se passera bien c'est absurde il faut le
jardin c'est pas ça le jardin c'est la
planète c'est comment est-ce qu'on fait
ensemble et c'est très compliqué de
faire des choses ensemble il y a pas de
gouvernance mondiale il y a pas de
policier mondial il y a pas de maître du
monde regardez l'exemple de l'Union
européenne qui quand même c'est les pays
qui se connaissent le plus depuis plus
longtemps prenez l'exemple de la France
et de l'Angleterre on se C depuis 1000
ans voilà mais en même temps on se
connaî on peut pas dire qu'on quand
quand l'US on lui demande est-ce que
vous êtes est-ce que vous êtes amis de
Monsieur Macron et de la France je sais
pas après 1000 ans sa toujours pas si on
est amis alors après vous allez vous
mettre dans un format G20 et vous dites
bonà dans la salle on a l'Arabie
Saoudite la Turquie l'Argentine la Corée
les Français les Anglais et cetera vous
pensez que naturellement on va avoir un
consensus et pourtant il faut qu'on
fasse avec on fait avec mais il y a
peut-être des moyens on arrête d'écouter
ses copains on évite de faire les five
on évite de torpiller les marchés des
uns et des autres on se donne la main
pour avancer ensemble est-ce qu'à force
d'élever des requins
et qu'on met à la tête de nos états ça
nous retombe un peu dessus parce qu'ils
se font la GU guerre c'est un petit peu
c'est c'est c'est niveau des mois
quilevont des requins c'est la nature
humaine enfin je malheureusement c'est
le le le romancier américain Jonathan
Franzen qui qui qui disait Forton il y a
2 ans qui était malheureusement assez
négatif en disant on n'y arrivera pas
pour deux raisons les États ne se font
pas confiance et la nature humaine bon
bah à ce on peut baisser les bras on
part dans le cynisme on dit bah je je
m'en fous plein les poches et tant pis
c'est pas le c'est pas le le choix que
ouais il y a des gens qui font ça après
tout moi j'entends des gens qui me
disent regardez Peter te qui a acheté un
grand domaine en Nouvelle-Zélande sur le
thème si tout marche
si ça marche pas j' en Nouvelle-Zélande
c'est le point qui est le plus éloigné
de tous le changement climatique sera
pas trop brutal là où il a fait son
boomker ou vous avez un boomker pardon
vous avez un boomker ma foi comment ma
foi pas mal belle répartie écoutez ça
protège pas contre les bombes nucléaires
pardon ça protège pas contre bombe
nucléaire
revenons à la guerre économique est-ce
que vous trou non que c'est que la
difficulté c'est qu'on a on a cette
feuille de route planétaire qui pour moi
est un peu il faut pas mais qui est
possiblement le champ du signe de cette
espèce de de mondialisation heureuse
champ du signe quelle couleur le signe
bah pour l'instant blanc qui qui est un
peu le champ du signe de cette
mondialisation heureuse o on s'est mis
d'accord sur une feuille de route
alors après on peut dire c cette feuille
de route est ridicule évidemment qu'on a
envie d'érradiquer la pauvreté on a
envie que les gens aient accès à la
santé il faut vraiment être un salot
pour dire j'ai pas envie que les gens
aient accès à la santé donc on a tous
signé ça mais on l' quand même signé
simplement et et rappelez-vous c'était
intéressant il y a eu une poignée de
main quand l'impression que c'était il y
a 1000 an quand on y réfléchi entre
Barack Obama et shijinping à l'automne
en disant on est d'accord on y va et et
moi comme beaucoup d'autres j'ai cru que
c'était bon je me dis c'est c'est parti
malheureusement 6 mois après le brexit 1
an après Trump 18 mois après le congrès
du Parti communiste et le système par
env et on partle dans un système qui
n'est plus du tout dans l'esprit de 2015
alors on peut dire c'était les bisoun
nours tout ce qu'on veut mais n'empêche
que ça nous oblige toujours
juridiquement c'est toujours les papiers
qui sont sur la table signés par tout le
monde simplement on voit bien où on est
8 9 10 ans plus tard on est juste pas en
ligne ni sur le climat ni sur la
biodiversité ni sur la pauvreté ni sur
la santé ni sur rien du tout Gutierrez
disait le secrétaire Gén des Nations
Unies disait en septembre l'année
dernière nous avons ouvert les portes de
l'enfer il disait sur les sur les
objectifs il y en a je plus c'est 83 au
87 % peu importe euh donc c'est ce qu'il
a annoncé en septembre aux Nations Unies
euh sur lesquels on est soit en retard
soit en marche arrière
80 plus de 80 % donc en fait la feuille
de route on on l'ignore on n'est plus du
tout et et pourquoi parce que on a
toutes ces forces centrifuges qui se
déploient euh qui sont en partie ce
changement d'état d'esprit que j'ai que
j'ai cité le fait que l'entrée de la
Chine et de la Russie dans l'OMC a juste
pas changé qu'on s'est fait on était des
naïfs euh
et et et que la crise en Irak la crise
financière et puis le le comportement
occidental au début de la crise
sanitaire ont pas été un moment de
d'extase totale par rapport au reste du
monde donc c'est pas des bons chrétiens
quoi pardon c'est pas des bons chrétiens
ouais je dirais pas comme ça mais non
non mais mais mais mais mais on voit
bien qu'aujourd'hui on a et pour moi
c'est un des enjeux
majeurs au-delà de la guerre économique
la guerre économique après tout pe avoir
des guerres de haute ou basse intensité
et cetera pour moi l'enjeu majeur c'est
qu'on fait pas planète aujourd'hui c'est
c'est c'est c'est bien le problème c'est
que on est un moment où les défis je je
reprends la métaphore de Voltaire le
jardin le jardin c'est pas c'est pas mon
petit jardin mon backyard mon petit truc
c'est notre planète la la question du
climat la question de la biodiversité la
question de l'égalité entre les hommes
et les femmes c'est c'est quelque chose
qui qui nous concerne tous c'est pas une
bataille qui va se livrer à Bruxelles à
Washington elle va se livrer à Bruxelles
à Washington mais elle va aussi se
livrer à legos à Bogota à des et ce ETA
et si on fait pas planète on n arrivera
pas encore une fois la tonne de CO2
qu'on économise en France si elle crache
au nigéa bilan ça va pas et plus on
laisse ces forces centrifuges plus on
laisse cette espèce de paradigme de
guerre économique imprégner les esprits
euh moi on a de chance d'y arriver et
c'est pour ça que je suis pas très
optimiste aujourd'hui en réalité vous
anticipez quel type de risque quel type
de menace
pour moi la alors on
on peut regarder les choses y a pas mal
de manières de regarder les sujets mais
pour moi la la la la menace euh fondam
court moyen et long terme non mais la
menace d'ailleurs c'est un peu la même à
court moyen et long terme c'est est-ce
que on a un défi planétaire qui est
je je pardon j'ai un peu l'esprit
d'escalier rappelez-vous Milton Friedman
l'objet social de l'entreprise c'est de
maximiser le profit et donc le profit
comme fin en soi et c'est le système qui
nous emmène dans le mur j'aime bien la
formule d'un ancien doyen de la Business
School d'Oxford qui s'appelait Colin qui
s'appelle d'ailleurs il est pas mort qui
s'appelle Colin meer qui disait l'objet
social de l'entreprise c'est pas de
maximiser le profit l'objet social de
l'entreprise c'est trouver des solutions
profitables euh au problème de la
planète et de ses habitants il dit pas
que le profit c'est mal il faut un
niveau de profit mais ce profit est
légitime parce qu'il est lié à des
solutions au problème de la planète
parce que pour l'instant on a pas
d'autres planètes peut-être que musk
nous emmènera sur Mars enfin a priori
pas tout de suite et de ses habitants et
et et donc c'est bien ça il faut
remettre l'économie au service de notre
planète et de ses habitants et la
planète et ses habitant on y arrivera
que ensemble
on va pas faire le sauvetage de la
pleine dans un seul pays ça n'existe pas
et donc c'est pour ça que mon combat
aujourd'hui c'est de travailler à ce
qu'on amende ce système qu'on sorte de
ce système qui qui date de 50 ans qui
nous emmène dans le mur et qu'on
transforme pour arriver à quelque chose
le principal obstacle pour revenir à
votre facteur de risque c'est la
désagrégation du monde c'est ses forces
centrifuge qui fait que depuis votre
quartier jusqu'à discussion entre les
États-Unis et la Chine on commence par
s'engueuler avant de faire quoi que ce
soit tout devient plus violent tout
devient plus incivil tout devient plus
égoïste et cetera
et donc on se retrouve dans un monde où
tout le monde est crispect on a deux
gros déficits qui un déficite
d'innovation et un déficite de
générosité je jouralist ça fait un peu
boy SC Cato mais ouais c'est important
la générosité je pense queant les B coup
de câau oui bah oui heureusement qu'il y
en a de temps en temps ou pas assez
souvent des gens comme vous pardon il y
en a pas assez souvent des gens comme
vous il y en a plus qu'on croit je je me
se cach pardon ils se cachent ben non
vous vous me mettez vous me révélez ce
soir non mais parce que on s'est croisé
dans une Abay c'est mais pour moi on on
est vraiment un moment en tout cas il
faut pas que les gens se cachent je
reviens à Paul Volker n'acceptez pas le
système si vous trouvez qu'il y a un
problème dites-le faites-le et c'est
maintenant qu'il faut qu'il faut se
lever c'est maintenant qu'il faut dire
les choses ne vont pas mais c'est vrai
mais mais c'est vrai que c'est très dur
parce que souvent les gens me disent
mais attendez moi j'y peux rien regardez
les la Chine et les États-Unis et
qu'est-ce que je suis moi par rapport à
la Chine les États-Unis c'est à la fois
vrai et c'est vrai que si SH Jin ping
décide d'attaquer taiïwan ni vous ni moi
on pourra y faire grand chose en fait et
en même temps c'est pas vrai parce que
tous en tant qu'on soit citoyen
consommateur investisseurs adhérant un
parti politiquement une association on
peut élever la voix les techniques
modernes les réseaux sociaux et cetera
peuvent faire des effets de masse donc
encore une fois même en Chine il y a une
forme d'opinion ENF donc il faut si
effectivement on baisse les bras et tout
effectivement là il se passera plus rien
donc je pense que le parfois quand les
jours où je vais pas je dis il faut
imaginer siisif heureux j'ai
l'impression que je pousse mon rocher
bah voilà c'est un peu comme si ZIF le
myth là on pousse puis le rocher tombe
on repousse il retombe on repousse il
retombe et cetera mais c'est quand même
voilà cette action c'est ce qui donne
sens à notre vie et et quand quand il
retombe vous le polissez un peu votre
pierre la votre pierre vous la polissez
un petit peu heureusement que j'apprends
à chaque fois on progresse mais mais
pour moi c'est pour ça qu'on est à un
moment très important le le le le le
système tel qu'il a fonctionné de depuis
50 ans il ne marche pas il s'est
fragmenté il ne marche pas mais on voit
pas le nouveau système émerger et et et
c'est très compliqué parce qu'encore une
fois il y a pas de maître du monde parce
que il y a des forces centrifuges qui
font que les les les gens se parlent de
moins en moins et qu'on a un petit sujet
occidental en plus c'estàdire que
effectivement ce monde il était plutôt
on appelit onappelait pas le consensus
de Beijing ou le consensus de Delhi on
l'appelait le consensus de Washington
ce monde il était quand même comme je
disis sou c'était un monde G7 c'est que
les pays du G7 structure inventée par la
France en 1975 euh B en fait dictter
l'agenda des réunions de Bretons et
cetera en c'était eux qui qui étaient
l'agenda international aujourd'hui c'est
plus le cas on est dans un monde G20 ou
alors même certains disent un monde G0
parce que en fait il y a plus personne
j'ai m entendu quelqu'un qui dit c'est
même pas un monde ça peut être un monde
G2 États-Unis Chine ou même certains
c'est un monde G- 2 parce comme ils
s'entendent tellement pas en fait on est
en force négative donc on a un système
qu'on a qu'on a du mal à voir émergé où
il y a un certain nombre de pays nous
disent écoutez-moi
l'Occident voahà c'est lecture c'est
exactement ça vous nous faites la morale
vous nous dites qu'il faudrait qu'on se
comporte comme C ou comme ça mais vous
nous aidez plus financièrement les flux
publics se tarissent les flux privés
sont très faibles et vous voulez en plus
que je m'aligne avec vous dans les votes
sur le Hamas ou sur la Russie mais
attendez comme m'a dit un dirigeant
africain il m'a dit moi
vous avez un problème avec la Chine vous
avez un problème avec la Russie moi j'ai
un problème avec avec ma population
alors aidez-moi avec ma population et
après je m'occuperai de problème avec la
Russie et la Chine mais me demandez pas
en plus de m'aligner si vous mettez pas
avec ma population est-ce que la monnaie
c'est de l'énergie ou est-ce que c'est
un vecteur d'énergie
non la monie c'est la monnaie c'est pour
moi c'est on revient à la question
précédente c'est c'est une question de
confiance pour moi c'est c'est le c'est
c'est un des cimentss sociaux
il y a pas d'énergie derrière après
c'est ça permet d'acheter de l'énergie
ça perce les flux est-ce que les flux
stariss parce que l'Occident manque
d'énergie d'énergie au sens calorifique
du terme calorifique du terme après il
faut interroger l'excellent Jean-Marc
jovissi qui a des théories très
intéressantes sur le sujeti j'ai pas
j'ai pas poussé j'ai pas de réflexion
particulière sur ce sujet là question
internet non pas tout de suite les
questions internet
revenons revenons à la guerre économique
la mondialisation heureuse et tout c'est
bullshit World
vous voyez pas émerger le système non
c'est parce que vous avez pas les bonnes
lunettes vous êtes pas assez possédé par
le démon c'est pourquoi que vous voyez
pas le nouveau système émer peut-être
parce que je suis extra lucide ou ça
c'est peut-être un peu présompt dire ça
devin ou astrologue non c'est parce que
j'ai eu la chance je reviens à ce que je
disais tout à l'heure sur Forest Gump
j'ai eu la chance non planifiée de voir
le système surous toutes ces facettes
presque toutes ces facette et donc d'en
voir sa force mais aussi ses faiblesses
la gouvernance mondiale quand les gens
dis ils ont qu'à décider ça att encore
une fois vous mettez dans une salle et
vous dites ok alors on va se mettre
d'accord sur tel ou tel règle entation
avec les argentins qui ont leurs
problèmes les Coréens qui ont les leurs
les Chinois les Indiens d'ailleurs
Poutine n' pas le droit de venir parce
qu'on est en guerre et puis shijin ping
vient pas parce que ceci enfin c'est
faut faut pas se raconter des histoires
je peux raconter une belle histoire en
disant on a signé des accords c'est
compliqué mais on va y arriver je
préfère arriver avec les yeux grand
ouverts en disant oui ben il faut se
retrousser les manches et il faut y
aller
un des sujets que j'avais soulevé à
l'époque en 2015 quand on a fait ses
accords qui reste malheureusement
d'actualité j'avais piloté un rapport
qui s'appelait à l'époque billions to
trillions al ça veut dire des milliards
au milliers de milliards pourquoi parce
que en 2015 les les les accords qu'on a
signé donc notamment les accords de
Paris sur le climat comme les objectifs
de développement durable les accords de
d'adisabeba sont point connus
développement durable c'est le petit
pins que j'ai ici euh en fait on on s
pas beaucoup va changer le monde on
s'est pas posé la question de savoir
combien ça a coûta le petit pins non le
pin ça ça va mais les changer le monde
donc alors on a fait des calculs MACR on
a dit ça va coûter 5 5000 milliards de
dollars par an 6000 milliards de dollars
par anon comme personne sait ce que
c'est que 6000 milliards vous savez mê
pas combien il zéro dans 6000 milliards
c'est beaucoup d'argent donc bonj'ui
c'est beaucoup d'argent mais bon et on
s'est pas posé la question de sair s'il
y avait ass d'argent on s'est pas posé
la question de savoir si le système
allait naturellement se mettre dans la
bonne direction est-ce que les
entreprises vont naturellement faire ce
qu'il faut vous et moi comme
consommateur et cetera on s'est dit
puisque les objectifs sont merveilleux
le système va se va va s'orienter en
fonction de ses objectifs c'était ça le
Paris un peu parce que italien de
l'époque on se met des objectifs ils
sont formidables on va y aller et
d'ailleurs la dynamique des accords de
Paris c'est celle-là on donne des
objectifs relativement réaliste et on se
dit tous les 5 ans on les durcit
naturellement volontairement c'est et
c'était c'était une belle mécanique
c'était probablement le prix à payer
pour qu'il soit accepté et donc dans le
rapport from billions to trillions ce
que ce que je dis c'est on a un problème
d'ordre de grandeur est-ce que vous
savez quelle est la taille de l'économie
mondiale euh 300000 à l'année oui 300
100000 milliards non trois fois moins g
les gens disent moins c'est très rare
que les gens disent plus que c'est
100000 100000 100000 milliards 100000
milliards d'accord en général les gens
disent 1000
façon au-delà de 100 milliards c'est
beaucoup on sait plus très bien enfin
100000 milliards ça c'est l'économie
mondiale à peu près en grande masse
moitié dans les économies avancées
moitié dans les économies émergentes en
développement et donc on a pris la
décision en 2015 de faire évoluer super
tanker de 100000 milliards par an les
trillions et on a dit bah c'est rien ça
coûte 5000 milliards par an mais c'est
pas grave puisqueil y a 250000 milliards
d'éparn ENF on sort les chiffres bon
donc c'est pas c'est pas compliquééparne
voilà et et et on a vendu d'une certaine
manière l'idée que c'était une
transition rappelez-vous on dit c'est
une transition
non moi non plus mais c'est comme ça
qu'on l'a vendu on a dit il suffit de
baisser vos émissions carbon de 1 ou 2 %
par an pendant 30 ans il suffit de
réallouer 1 ou 2 % de l'éparne mondial
par an pendant 30 ans il suffit de voilà
et en fait on vous a dit voilà vous êtes
au début de la plage vous allez à
l'autre bout de la plage vous avez 30
ans vous faites un pas tous les jours
même pas mal et vous allez vous dans 30
ans vous verrez dans un monde très
différent et en fait on se rend compte
10ant plus tard que 1 on n pas été
capable de réallouer ou de baisser il a
fallu le covid pour qu'on voit ce que ça
voulait dire de baisser de 5 % le CO2 il
a fallu tout arrêter donc on a pris
conscience que même ça on savait pas
faire et là aujourd'hui ça devient
difficile c'est qu'on se rend compte
queon est plus dans une transition on
est dans une transformation et ça c'est
beaucoup plus difficile parce que la
transformation ça nous touche tous et on
le gère pas et on le gère pas et dans
une transformation et on le voit bien
aujourd'hui en France il y a des
gagnants il y a des perdants il y a il y
a des gens à qui ça va coûter des gens à
qui ça va rapporter et CEA et il faut
pas nier tout ça et il faut rentrer dans
le dur de transformation de mode de
production de consommation de
financement et cetera donc soit on est
sérieux et on y va soit on n'est pas
sérieux on y va pas mais à ce moment là
il faut se préparer effectivement à un
monde qui va être chaud et violent alors
puisque vous on a joué au jeu
desvinettes oui
la consommation mondiale de pétrole en
millions de barils par jour c'est
combien euh
[Musique]
pas vous dire de par je raisonnais en
milliards de tonnes je suis plus en
millions de barils euh une centaine de
millions de barils par jour il y a
combien de litres dans un baril alors il
faut 7 barils pour faire une tonne 150 l
à peu près 156 5 et pourquoi c'est 156
aucune idée alors parce que avant on
mettait le pétrole dans des barils de
whisky ah ouis c'est bien hein voilà
à chaque période son ivresse pas mal pas
mal
euh qu'importe le contenant pourvu que
on est livresse soit là voilà qu'importe
le calice d'ailleurs je CIS pas mal pas
mal plus il est en terre cuite mieux
c'est et
le singral de l'uranium il faut combien
de tonnes d'uranium pour approvisionner
442 réacteurs nucléaires aucune idée
il y a combien de réacteurs nucléaires
sur terre euh
g à peu près les ordes de grandeur que
vousz dire 400 ou 500 je dirais parce
qu' avoir une soixantaine en France
qu'on est les États-Unis sont un peu
plus gros que nous je je ça mais j'ai
pas c'est pas des chiffres que je
connais donc la consommation béton en
France non ça ça me rappelle M mes
concours je sais pas tout ça c'est pas
les Français consomment combien de
calories par jour
je ne sais pas en alimentation je ne
sais pas
comment vous expliquez que les
agriculteurs soient dans la rue puisque
vous avez été au Crédit Agricole depuis
longtemps non j'ai été au crédit école
pas depuis longtemps j'ai été au
créditécole il y a longtemps pardon
excusez-moi
le Crédit Agricole une fois qu'on est
dedans on reste toujours au créitle ah
pas toujours justement mais c'est quoi
votre banque pardon c'est quoi votre
banque euh
j'ai un compte chez LCL qui dépend du
Crédit Agricole donc voilà donc je suis
toujours un peu de la famille un jour je
discutais avec un banquier qui était
plus grand que vous et on discutait des
crises et lui il avait à peu près 12 ou
13 ans d'avance sur votre prospective h
et il m'a dit il faut que tu sois dans
une banque qui a l'habitude de gérer ses
risques
ou là
une vieille banque qui a déjà traversé
ce type de problème qu'est-ce que vous
pensez de son conseil à toutes les
banques qu'on traversa des problèmes
alors après vous pouvez aller chez
revolut qui n'a pas encore rencontré de
problèm
non non ça c'est des trucs euh
mais pour revenir à votre question sur
les agriculteurs je trouve que c'est
c'est pour moi c'est très symptomatique
des en fait des impasses dans lesquel on
s'est mis c'estàd qu'on a eu une
approche très tableur Excel en fait de
de la question il faut euh PowerPoint
non non PowerPoint c'est c'est c'est
moins bien que table Excel table Excel
il y a quand même des cellules avec des
formules de PowerPoint c'est
mais mais
ce que je veux dire par là c'est que en
fait on on a dessiner ce monde en disant
voilà sil faut qu'on arrive à temps B
les efforts c'est t c'est ça c'est ça
c'est ça et donc on fait un Green Deal
et on se fixe des objectifs et on va y
arriver et
et ça ça je encore une fois c'est la
méthode technique mais ça la bonne
technique ne suffit pas à vendre dire
c'est pas il faut un produit séduisant
moi ce que je regrette beaucoup mais
c'est quoi un produit si division c'est
on va arrêter de se faire la guerreit
on main dans la main non non mais le le
ce qui est extraordinaire c'est qu'on on
a vendu un discours
d'effort
de punition de flagélationé
d'austérité ENF on a vendu un discours
qui est pas agréable c'est vous avez vu
la tête des gens qui nous ont vendu ça
c'est un peu normal non peut-être mais
mais alors que au fond on est quand même
en train de proposer une société dans
laquelle il y aura moins de pollution il
y aura moins de bruit enfin normalement
on a on aura pu avoir un discours quand
même plus vendeur sur le monde qu'on
voulez créer c'est peutêtre mais on est
passé par une phase ça va très mal se
terminer vous allez finir carboniser
vous allez vous allez pourir griller il
y aura plus plus d'animaux et je vous
coupe si vous m'autorisez oui bien sûr
on sera dans une ville sans bruit
qu'est-ce que vous avez dit d'autres il
y aura moins de pollution ou V il y aura
plus de fleurs et cetera il il y aura
peut-être plus de pollution chez les
chinois il y aura peut-être plus de
pollution en Afrique il y aura peut-être
des trous des trous il aura peut-être
des mines de cobalt avec des gamins qui
B non mais c'est là que vous touchez au
cœur de ma de mon engagement pour le
coup c'est c'est c'est pour moi c'est ce
qui et c'est pareil avec les
agriculteurs c'est qu'on peut pas
décider sur tableur Excel de transformer
la planète ça n'existe pas on va pas la
transformer tout seul je vaux pas faire
du populisme à de balles depuis un
bureau de Bruxelles mais les
agriculteurs on leur a dit c'est comme
ça il y a à la fois des problèmes très
objectifs de revenus enfin tout ce
qu'ils expriment de revenus de norme
mais aussi un problème de considération
on a dit vous êtes à Var d'ajustement en
gr c'est ça et on est tous un peu
coupables comme consommateur de produits
alimentaires par exemple euh et puis
surtout on a une vraie le point que vous
faites sur le cobalt et cetera il est
central et et pour moi c'est une erreur
majeure de l'Europe aujourd'hui
c'est c'est que euh on est insulaire
enin à stï ça marche avec la potion
magique malheureusement on n'a pas la
potion magique donc il faut qu'on aille
tendre un peu le bras au reste du monde
euh plutôt que d'antagoniser l'Afrique
l'Amérique latine et ca il faut aller
travailler avec eux plutôt que de faire
une réaction noire et blanc sur Mercosur
c'est pas bon ou c'est bon c'est c'est
ni pas bon ni bon il faut qu'on
travaille avec ces pays-là donc on a
encore une fois on va pas se sauver tout
seul et et malheureusement on est dans
une phase qui pour moi m'inquiète parce
que derrière ce côté guerre économique
qui a été accentué par le covid alors je
sais pas comment dire en français je je
dis en anglais inwarding c'estàd qu'on
se on se regarde le nombril bah de
nombrilisation euh aujourd'hui euh ça
revient un peu à ce que je disais tout à
l'heure sur le jardin aujourd'hui on est
très préoccupé euh de soi et ça quand je
vois ces 2 ans confiner chez vous vous
regardez et vous vous dites il est
suffisamment de problème chez moi pour
que je m'occupe pas du reste du monde et
et et et c'est c'est très c'est très
flagrant moi je le vois dans mon métier
qui est l'investissement est-ce que vous
avez une idée de la part de des actifs
financiers européens qui sont investis
dans les pays émergents en développement
donc Afrique Amérique latine Asie euh si
on joue encore au jeu des linettes bah
vous mavez posé plein je savais pas vous
avez le droit de pas savoir 2500 non non
je parle en pourcentage la proportion de
de 0,00 non non quand même pas 01 entre
de entre 3 et 4 % oh magnifique et aux
États-Unis entre 1 et 2 % on est trop
magnanime voilà alors que c'est 50 % de
l'économie mondiale donc ces pays nous
disent attendez vous voulez nous
embarquer mais vous nous imposez un
certain nombre de règles de normes vous
nous financez pas l'argent public les
flux sont plutôt en diminution donc on
est en train de créer une tension alors
qu'on devrait au contraire travailler
ensemble donc c'est pour ça qu'on s'est
fait bter le cul d'Afrique par les
Africains je pense que c'est une partie
de la raison oui je suis désolé d'être
vulgaire non non mais c'est c'est c'est
pas c'est pas la seule raison il y a
beaucoup il y a il y a beaucoup de
choses mais c'est vrai qu'aujourd'hui je
suis mal à l'aise et je le comprends
quand les gens nous parlent de
colonialisme vert ça c'est quand même un
sujet et de manière très intéressante
les États-Unis sont épargnés parce quee
façon les États-Unis on pense qu'ils
resteront un payv important et puissant
et l'Europe bah ça pati du fait que un
certain nombre de gens commencent à
penser qu'on est en train de sortir de
l'histoire si on se ressaisit pas ce ti
dis non non je pense pas qu'on se
tirmondise euh vous avez pas pris le
périphérique depuis longtemps vous
pardon vous avez pas pris le
périphérique depuis longtemps ah si ça
m'arrive j'ai pas de voiture mais je pr
ça monte à quand la dernière fois que
vous avez pris le métro ah bah pour
venir ici vous êtes passé par quelle
ligne je suis passé sur la ligne 1 et
puis après je suis château de Vincen la
défense euh pour enfin moi je l'ai pris
à Pont de jusqu'à
que je ne dis pas de bêtis chiser
clémceau et là j'ai pris la LI de TR
jusqu'à Saint-Lazare où j'avais un
rendez-vous et j'ai marché de
Saint-Lazare jusqu'ici
je vous ai coupé la parole
oui mais c'est pas la première fois ça
fait exprès vous sa j'ai bien compris on
parle un peu religion si vous voulez
j'aime pas trop en fait mais c'est vrai
pourquoi non parce que j'ai toujours
pensé que c'était une affaire assez
personnelle euh
et donc
le fait d'avoir la foi ne me rend ni
pire meilleur j'ai pas questionné votre
fois je voulais parler de religion et
système monétaire est-ce que les maîtres
de la propagande depuis les 2000
dernières années n'auraiit pas un peu
leur mot à dire j'ai un copain feu un
copain qui s'appelait Jacques Blamont
qui qui était ingénieur
qui a qui a conçu le programme spatial
français et il s'est rendu compte que
bon consommer de la viande c'était
compliqué pour la terre les sources
l'épuisement des ressources je vous l'
fait trivialement puis il s'est dit bon
je suis biographe officiel de Galilée
était un peu taquin il dit je vais aller
au Vatican je vais demander au pape qui
disent à ses oilles d'arrêter de manger
trop de viande parce que sinon ça va pas
être tenable bon il a pas été reçu par
le pape il a été reçu par le cardinal
noir qui a fait oui oui avec la tête
est-ce que les religion les religieux de
toute on va dire de toute obédience de
toute cour
ont pas un grand rôle à jouer moi je
crois en fait c'est amusant que vous
posez cette question parce que si si si
c'est amusant dans par rapport à mon
histoire personnelle parce que il y a 20
plus que ça je dire au siècle dernier on
va dire piquement
j'avais organisé à Dauphine à
l'université de Dauphine avec avec un
professeur de Dauphine qui s'appelait
s'appelle toujs Philippe chalemin un
séminaire dont on a fait un livre qui s
appel la mondialisation a-telle une âme
et ce ce séminaire le sous-titre plus
plus explicite c'était euh morale
spiritualité et vie des affaires et en
fait on s'était posé la question on a
fait ça 2 ans de suite en interrogeant
un certain nombre de de à la fois de
chefs d'entreprise et de prêtres de
Rabin d'imam et cetera euh pour savoir
si euh en tant que chef d'entreprise ou
religieux leur religion avait sur la la
vie économique un regard particulier et
à l'époque cé assez nouveau aujourd'hui
c'est il y a plus de gens qui font ça la
Banque mondiale notamment à tout un tout
un département sur ces questions là à
l'époque c'était assez nouveau et je me
souviens quand quand j'avais écrit
l'introduction de du livre qui était
sorti à l'époque donc la mondialisation
inelunâ j'avais j'avais dit de manière
un peu provocatrice au fond euh alors
toutes ces religions elles ont un
message important à faire passer mais
c'est c'est beaucoup plus compliqué
qu'il n'y paraît parce que le message
important c'est donnez-moi de la thune
non c'est que comment est-ce qu'on vit
ensemble comment est-ce qu'on fait
planète enfin c'est quand même ça vous
nous donnez de la tune non non c'est
c'est non mais justement c'est la la
question de la thune elle est elle est
intéressante parce que précisément c'est
là que c'est compliqué
toutes les religions globalement sont
d'accord pour tu ne tuuras point ENF il
y a personne qui dit que pour réussir il
faut tuer voilà ça c'est quand même on
peut c'est plutôt rassurant les croisade
tout ça c just ça ve pas dire qu'après
non ça veut pas dire qu'après il y a pas
eu des dérapages mais ENF
fondamentalement dans les précepts des
religions il y a personne qui dit pour
réussir dans les affaires faut tuer
c'est pas dire que les gens le font pas
mais en tout cas on ne leur prescrit pas
là où ça devient très intéressant c'est
quand on passe à tu ne voleras point
alors là c'est le feu d'artifice parce
que tu ne voleras point comment vous
définissez le vol et alors là vous avez
des milliers de livres qui ont été
écrits sur le juste prix
est-ce que si je suis épicier que je te
voendis un peu plus cher que et cetera
est-ce que je te vole où est-ce que je
fais mon métier comme avait dit à
l'époque et l'usure c'est ça l'usure
vous en parlez aussi je sais plus que
j'ai j'ai pas lu livre depuis 30 an mais
un exemple dont je me souviens qui était
intéressant qui était aussi un peu
simple voir simpliste mais amusant
c'était un un hindou qui me disait voilà
je suis réincarné en tant que chef
d'entreprise dans cette vie donc pour
réussir faut que je maximise mon profil
et cetera et on me dit pas très bien
comment donc après tout tous les moyens
sont bons pour que je sois mieux
réincarné donc l'idée de ton juste prix
moi si c'est du vol c'est pas grave bon
voilà après il y a une partie qui était
amusée une partie qui était sérieuse et
ce que je veux dire par là c'est que et
et on revient à l'idée de la spéculation
revient à toutes ces idées là est-ce que
les régions ont quelque chose à nous
dire sur ce juste prix ou est-ce que
c'est un exercice sans fin qui qui
intéresse les gens et qui font des
volume mais c'est c'est intéressant de
voir que tu ne tueras point ok tu ne
voleras point ah bah oui ça c'est ça on
des vrais débats question internet
bonsoir comment votre invité
appréhendet-il l'innovation financière
qui pourrait représenter le proto que
pourrait représenter le protocole
Bitcoin comme décrit dans le White Paper
de Satoshi Nakamoto alors c'est une
question sur laquelle je c'est c'est un
des sujets sur lequel je n'arrive pas à
stabiliser ma pensée euh
la réponse que je fais ce soir sera pas
la même que demain soir et sera pas la
même qu'hier c'est le temps de vous
engager en politique alors pardon c'est
le temps de vous engager en politique
non non mais c'est c'est c'est il y a
une partie de moi qui est naturellement
très curieuse et qui qui regarde ça avec
beaucoup d'attention depuis l'origine
qui se dit effectivement c'est c'est
c'est d'ailleurs une partie de de de la
réponse à la crise de confiance par
rapport à la monnaie et cetera enfin on
se dit c'est pas la seule mais en tout
cas il y a un vrai questionnement de
notre système et on dit bon voilà c'est
le côté mes 68 si vous voulez je je
passe côté rebelle
et c'est intéressant le le le le toute
la technologie qui s'est développée
derrière sur le blockchain est
intéressant en fait il y a beaucoup
beaucoup de choses très intéressantes
derrière tout ça en même temps je ne le
ni pas j'ai passé beaucoup de temps
comme représentant de la Banque de la
Banque mondiale au G20 j'ai passé
beaucoup de temps avec des banquiers
centraux et cetera qui m'ont quand même
convaincu que c'était c'était quelque
chose de pas de pas très sain qu'il y
avait beaucoups on a vu encore
aujourd'hui j'ai j'ai pas eu le temps de
voir les détails mais une opération en
Allemagne ils ont saisi 2 milliards et
demi d'équivalent Bitcoin chez des
criminels enfin il y a quand même des
choses voilà là là on n'est pas dans
dans dans dans les bisoun nours voilà
voilà on ESS on quand même il y a quand
même des des des choses donc la réponse
est je ne sais pas ça m'intéresse
j'essaie de comprendre j'ai pas d'avis
parce que je il y a des jours où je me
dis ça ne tient pas la route et c'est
plutôt ma pensée dominante mais elle est
pas écrasante je donc je suis curieux de
voir comment ça va se développer mais
j'aimerais bien avoir une réponse
définitive claire et convainquante je la
réponité c'est que je ne l'ai pas je sur
ce sujet là c'est un sujet qui me
perturbe en tout cas
ça vous perturbe parce que vous
comprenez pas oui sans général ce qui se
passe ou oui question internet
pouvez-vous nous expliquer pourquoi en
ce moment les financiers s'inquiète de
la situation sur le marché monétaire
américain et parle d'un assèchement de
liquidité qui pourrait faire craindre
une crise financière et faire bouger la
Réserve fédérale américaine alors c'est
pas non plus ma spécialité mais c'est
vrai c'est un peu moins en ce moment
c'était plus le cas l'année dernière où
il y a eu effectivement des des tensions
en fait on oublie souvent que la finance
c'est aussi des tuyaux c'est aussi des
acteurs c'est aussi des décisions et
cetera et que quand on revient au thme
de waren Buffett quand la Maré baisse
euh ben les tuyaux peuvent être mis sous
pression il peut y avoir un certain
nombre de comportements on avait eu ça
en en 2008
2008 2009 2010 2011 euh là pour le coup
j'étais en première ligne donc je peux
parler de ce qui s'est passé à à
l'époque et même si les les aspects
techniques sont pas les mêmes
aujourd'hui c'est le même type de de de
tension vous avez fait un ulcère de
l'estomac à l'époque non non mais je des
nuits où je dormais pas très bien et
les banques françaises début 2011 euh se
refinancer c'est-à-dire qu'elle elle
récupérait de l'épargne américaine se
refinancer en dollar pour prêter en en
Europe enfin en France et j'ai plus les
chiffres exacts en tête mais les ordres
de grandeur c'était quand même pour
chacune des des trois grandes banques
Crédit Agricole Société Générale et BNP
Paribas c'était probablement de 50 à 80
milliards de dollars de qui étaient
prêtés à très court terme
et qu'on on roulait l'idée c'est que ça
se passait naturellement enfin c'était
et
et en fait à un moment donné la Réserve
fédérale cétait pas encore la guerre
économique a dit il y a eu un communiqué
disant nous sommes préoccupés euh de ce
phénomène et là immédiatement
[Musique]
c'est retirer et c'est là que les
banques françaises ont failli partir
dans le mur c'est d'un seul coup et
c'était un truc alors qu'on pensait que
ça marcherait toujours ça dire quoi
partir dans le mur bah vous avez plus de
financement bah vous voilà vous avez
plus fonctionner enfin c'est le VIX il
était à combien à l'époque pardon le VIX
il était à combien à l'époque
voà vous posz une colle c'est quoi le
VIX le VIX c'est l'indice de volatilité
sur les marchés qui met quippelle
l'indice de la peur c'estàdire que euh
là aujourd'hui il doit être entre 20 et
30 il a pu monter à 50 60 70 dans les
dans les dans les grandes années euh
donc c'est vrai qu'entre entre 2008 et
2011 on a eu plusieurs fois très peur et
et au moment de la crise de 2008 pareil
le marché monétaire américain ce qu'on
appelit bre the buck normalement un fond
monétaire ça descend jamais en dessous
d'un dollar parce norre capital est
garanti c'est passé dessous en parti
pour des raisons techniques donc les
gens on eu peur donc je suis pas
spécialiste de ces questions techniques
mais c'est vrai que c'est des sujets
auquel il faut faire attention parce que
c'est c'est dans ces cas-là que que le
système peut péter là on le voit on
l'attend pas quoi est-ce qu'on a sauvé
la Grèce pour sauver les banques
françaises ah non est-ce que les banques
françaises avaient les j'aurais aimé
qu'on sauve la Grèce pour sauver
l'Europe mais pas pour sauver les
banques françaises est-ce que les
banques françaises étaient très exposées
à la Grèce ah bah je parler du Crédit
Agricole moi j'étais directeur financier
oui on était exposé la graisse mais
comme toutes les autres banques hauteur
de combien euh
alors c'est une somme de plusieurs
choses euh non non mais c'est pas
le le
une somme c'est quoi une somme non mais
je dis d'autant plus facilement parce
que je je je vais tirer gloire de ça
c'est c'est c'est une décision de di
financier dont je suis très fier euh non
si si bah j'ai le droit quand même de
temps en temps n pas attention hein
c'est péché c'est péché oui non non mais
je
les banques françaises la Société
Générale des crédit agricolees possédait
une banque en grce donc était exposé en
tant qu'actionnaire d'une banque en
Grèce au risque grec ensuite vous aviez
dans le bilan des banques comme dans le
bilan des compagnies d'assurance
appartenant aux banques de la dette grec
et c'est vrai je reviens rappelez-vous
le contexte 2001 2006 d'abord on savait
pas que les chiffres Grecs étaient
trafiqués il y avait quand même une
fraud qui c'est qui a trafiqué les
chiffres Grecs déjà bah le Premier
ministre de l'époque avec une banque
Goldman SAXS qui a aidé à l'époque et il
y avait pas une histoire dragy avait pas
aidé un petit peu à faire du window
dressing de tout ça non alors il y a une
assimilation entre le fait que dragy
travaill chez Goldman sach je suis pas
ah c'est Goldman sax qui a aidé à à
enjoliver les choses je sais pas si
c'est enjoliv en tout cas ils ont pris
une technique qui permet éé de de
déconsolider une partie de la dette et
donc Deo c'était légal c'était licite ah
c'est à légal je sais pas en tout cas
c'était une fraude qui a été qui a été
aidée par le mais peu importe le le
c'est pas merci de m'avoir corrigé
d'ailleurs non non mais c'est c'est
c'est pas le point que je voulais faire
la
la dette grecque dans les années 2000
c'était euh
que disaient les gens c'est la zone euro
c'est du un pays émergent avec le ris de
la zone euro donc je gagne dans les deux
cas bon évidemment ça va pas ça a pas
marché et et c'est vrai que la dette
grecque elle est c'était le même prix
que la dette allemande entre 2001 et
2007 ça rrangeait bien les Allemands
mais ça oui parce qu'il vendait des
choses en Grèce mais bien sûr mais tout
le monde il trouvait son compte jusqu'à
ce que le truc soit soit plus tenable et
donc un certain nombre de de banqu et
d'assureurs ont acheté de la dette
grecque donc ça ça était la ça a été la
deuxième source de perte et puis la
troisième qui était en fait indirect
c'est que le le la la crise grecque a
fait failli faire sauter le système
jusqu'à ce que Mario dragi intervienne
et donc toute tout le système a pati
pourquoi les dollars sont repartis aux
États-Unis parce que les dollars avaient
peur de la crise grecque donc il y a des
effets direct direct quand vous avez une
banque en Grèce il y a des effets enfin
direct direct quand vous avez des
investissements en det grec et il y a
des effets indirects qui est la la
perturbation du système et donc pour
revenir sur sur le montant des pertes
les montants des pertes sur les banques
c'était pas c'était pas très gros je va
pas vous dire je même pas parce que je
les ai plus en tête c'est quelques c'est
beaucoup c'est quelques milliards mais
c'est pas des dizaines ou des centaines
de milliards parce que c'éta pas des
très grosses banques euh là où je suis
fier pardon c'est que donc le Crédit
Agricole avait une banque en Grèce
on nomme un nouveau dirigeant à un
moment du début de la crise grecque et
dans les discussions une des hypothèses
qui est avancé c'est de dire on pourrait
acheter de la dette grecque on est avant
la révélation de la fraude on pourrait
acheter de la dette grecque ce qui nous
donnerait des ressources pour pouvoir
financer la restructuration de la banque
et ça voulait dire quoi ça veut dire que
à l'époque la Grèce commençait à
s'endetter un peu plus cher donc la
dette grecque devait rapporter du 6 ou 7
% on est on est début de je dis pas de
bêtisse début 2009 euh et euh donc vous
achetez cette dette grecque et puis vous
vous la mettez en garantie à la Banque
centrale européenne qui vous la
refinance à 1 %. et donc vous gagnez
l'échang 5 ou 6 % et cetera et j'ai dit
euh
au dirigeant j'ai dit ça tu fais pas ça
tu fais ta restructuration nous on gère
le bilan mais tu achètes pas de dette
grecque et donc quand la quand la la
dette a été restructurée le cré cré
agricole avait une exposition au titre
de ses assurances mais comme tous les
assurur Européens mais n'avait pas
d'exposition de det grec dans la banque
Bou non j'étais non mais honnêtement
c'est il y a deux trois décions je les
prends je les illustre auprès de mes
étudiants ce ce que je dis toujours à
mes étudiants moi je suis parentier j'ai
hérité d'un cerveau qui fonctionne à peu
près bien d'une certaine probité et et
donc quand je prends des décisions je
protège ma réputation
c'est ça c'est ça ma valeur c'est et
donc quand il y a des décisions comme ça
il y en a quelquesunes et celle-là oui
je suis assez fier d'avoir dit non c'est
pas t job de prendre la dette grec et
donc on na pas acheté 3 milliards de det
grec en 2009 qui aurait été 3 milliards
qu'on aurait jeté par la fenêtre gagnez
combien à l'époque pardon vous gagnez
combien à l'époque mon salaire alors je
vais pas vous donner la réponse pour
quoi et je VO donne-moi la batte de
baseball on va le faire parler un peu oh
vous arriverez pas je vois je vois j'ai
j'ai do j'ai lu le manuel de la de la
torture de la
il y a une sal de 2000 personnes qui n'y
est pas arrivé et je vais vous raconter
une vraie anecdote nous sommes en mars
2009 les autres c'était des fausses
les autres non non non j'aime bien les
his VO une vraie anecdote au sens
genuine pardon je suis désolé j'ai passé
10 ans aux États-Unis je mélange un peu
j'essaie de pas mélanger le français et
anglais mais non non mais une anecdote
qui était très très révélatrice on est
en mars 2009 donc je suis directeur
financier du Crédit Agricole c'est la
panique en France
après la crise de les man brows les
actions de l'État et cetera et donc on
m'a invite à aller parler à l'Assemblée
enfin un rassemblement à Blois que pas
la ville la plus extrémiste de France
dans le multiplexe de Blois sypa ah
c'est sympa Caisse régionale du Crédit
Agricole
et il y a 2000 personnes dans la salle
et je c'était un peu mon bisutage
derrière moi il y avait le directeur
général de la Caisse régionale et le
président de la Caisse régionale qui est
devenu depuis le président du groupe
cétais un peu don j'étais sur une scène
vide les deux dirigeants derrière moi
2000 personnes devant la France en
panique je fais mon numéro de claquette
comme ce soir j'explique bah la crise
mais écoutez voilà on a pris des
dispositions c'est pas simple j'essaie
d'expliquer au moins ce que c'est que le
subpre ENF je un truc et je parle
pendant une une bonne heure et à la fin
question réponse et première question et
c'était c'était c'était très émouvant
d'ailleurs on sentait une salle qui
était qui était qui avait plus serpè et
c'est ça le Crédit Agricole donc tu la
la la France c'est c'est c'est un bon
concentré de France quoi et Monsieur qui
se lève probablement extrêmement âgé
qui qui vraiment fait je pense que
quelqu'un qui n'avait pas l'habitude de
prendre la parole en public qui avait
pas l'habitude de parler à je dire un
monsieur de Paris pour faire cours qui
s'appuie sur sa cane mais tremblant
enfin un peu papis moujot c'est l'image
que j'avais et
qui me dit Monsieur vraiment très
intéressant ce que vous avez dit mais
moi j'ai quand même une question combien
c'est-il qui sont payés tous ces
messieurs qui nous ont foutu dans la
merde et qui font que mon fils ma fille
mes petits enfants enfant tout le monde
est au chômage et que la France va dans
le mur et cetera ça sera tout et le mec
il arrive pas à se rassoir il est avec
sa chaise et il chercher vouscheter la
canenne dessus non mais je je finis
l'histoire est pas finie pardon je suis
je suis long mais et donc je lui dit
écoutez monsieur
alors à l'époque on avait mis en place
un système pour encadrer les
rémunérations des brokers enfin des gens
sur les marché j'explique le système
effectivement il y avait un problème et
on est en train de le changer c'était
pas parfait depuis on a fait des progrès
les dirigeants à l'époque avait renoncé
à tous leurs bonus et cetera donc ça
aussi c'était publique et donc je donne
tout ça euh et puis je dis après il y a
différents métiers dans la banque ils
sont plus ou moins impacté et cetera et
et je lui dis euh moi je suis très bien
rémunéré j'ai pas de problème je suis
très bien rémunéré je je vais avoir les
conséquences du fait que la banque
performe moins mais ça c'est partie des
risques du métier euh donc j'ai pas de
gêne à vous dire que je suis bien
rémunéré et alors là il y a quelque
chose de complètement inattendu euh
donc il me dit je lui dis est-ce que ça
vous satisfit il me dit oui il se
rassoit et après on a le V d'honneur et
là il y a un monsieur qui arrive et là
aussi assez âgé qui hurle comme parfois
peut les personnes âgées qui dit alors
là Monsieur Badré je voulais vous dire
vous vous souvenez pas de moi alors je
dis ah non je me souviens pas de vous il
me dit j'étais le le l'employé de la
caisse de Lazard je dis bon par que vous
avez travaillé chez Lazard travill chez
Lazard et alors il dit à tout monsieur
Badré là chez Lazard là les gens il
gagnaient beaucoup d'argent là alors
quand il était le créécole c'est pour en
gagner moins ce monsieur est un héros
fait pas trop quand même
c'était extraordinaire c'était la la
chute et alors effectivement après voilà
donc en fait vous gagnez combien pardon
vous gagnez combien à l'époque non je
gagné très bien ma vie c'est combien
très bien pas très bien c'est pas
c'était pas des salaires américains
c'était vous payez c'était plusieurs
centaines de milliers d'euros c'est ça
votre question par an ou par mois non
par an des l'optimisation fiscale non
vous avez toujours payer vos impôts en
France bah quand j'étais en France oui
quand j'étais aux États-Unis non mais
vous payez toujours des impôts aux
États-Unis là non ça fa parti des sujets
compliqué parce que j'avais une carte
verte que j'ai rendu parce que
précisément ça rendait ma vie infernale
donc j'ai rendu ma carte verte et je
suis complètement fiscalisé en France
euh
question question internet la PO on
reviendra sur l'IRAC un petit peu ça r
d'être intéressant une petite question
Internet le risque de faillite des
petites banques américaine entre
parenthèses silicone valyban est-il
réellement derrière nous point
interrogation qu'en est-il en Europe
alors aux États-Unis je suis pas sûr
qu'il soit complètement derrière nous ce
qui est ce qui est très quand on trèsant
quand on prend une une perspective un
peu longue sur la finance américaine ce
qui est caractéristique je parlais de la
banque de Lucky Luc tout à l'heure où
vous aviez la nottingles Bank là je sais
pas quoi banque il en avait partout
c'est une concentration permanente que
le nombre de banques aux états-unus n'a
pas cessé de diminuer alors parfois de
manière régulière parfois paras quand il
y a une gra ris comme diminuer ou de se
racheter entre le nombre diminue non
dimin parce qu'elle se rachète entre ell
enfin c'est c'est vraiment un système et
à la fin c'est JP Morgan qui gagne parce
que c'est eux qui finissent par racheter
ch voilà et donc on on a une
concentration du système bancaire
américain qui à mon avis n'est pas
terminé il y a une tension très forte
sur les les banques régionales
précisément parce que la la crise de la
Silicon Valley de j'ai plus le nom des
deux autres
à rappelé que ces banques étaient plus
fragiles en partie d'ailleurs du fait de
Trump parce que que les les législations
plus dures qui avaient été adopté après
la crise financière
l'administration Trump avait la Réserve
fédérale avait exempter les banques de
moins de 250 milliards de bilan ce qui
quand même relativement gros déjà et
donc elles avaient pas le même niveau de
suivi que les autres donc c'est je pense
qu'on est en train de revenir là-dessus
mais il y a un risque
un risque en tout cas il y a une
faiblesse structurelle en Europe il y a
pas beaucoup de petites banques quand
vous regardez en France marché français
c'est quelques banques ça c'est pas
elles vont bien les banques françaises
oui plutôt mieux que la moyenne oui
elles ont des des fonds propres corrects
en qure carton ou oui oui genre balle 1
balle 2 balle 3 bal 3 non bal 3
maintenant bal 3 bal 3 donc le trou le
trou on peut le combler s'il y a un gros
crash ah pour le coup c'est c'est ce qui
a été décidé
pour moi c'était la partie facile de la
de la réponse à la crise financière de
de 2010 on a une réponse réglementaire
du bla bla quoi ah bah non quand quand
vous doublez vos fonds propres c'est pas
du blbl faut aller les chercher et
regardez le le prix fond pro par rapport
à l'exposition non mais vous regardez
une banque comme JP Morgan aujourd'hui
ça vaut plusieurs centaines de milliards
de dollars BNP qui est la première
banque française ça vaut plusieurs
dizaines de milliards de dollars c'est
ça qui s'est passé
parce que on a fait les efforts enfin je
c'est non il y a quand même une il y a
quand même une vérité des prix ce que je
veux dire aujourd'hui c'est que vous
avez des banques qui sont très bien
capitalisées on s'est posé la question
des capitaux et de l'accès les liquidité
donc on a des banques qui sont solides
la question qu'on s'est pas posé
l'expression que j'employé à l'époque
c'est on a fait le le on a fait le com
on appelle ça le le fond de garantie des
dépôts bancaires non non c'est pas ça
que je pensais pardon le
en marine quand on quand on fait enfin
on fait le radouble du bateau on colmate
les brèches le carénage non justement on
n pas fait le carénage on a colmaté les
brèches on a pas fait le grand carénage
pas mal et et et donc en fait on a on a
dit on va mettre des ratios on va
demander des certain nombre d'exigences
supplémentaires qui fait qu'on a des des
trucs très lourds vous avz maquillé la
vieille quoi non non non non on l'a
vraiment renforcé enfin c'est pour beau
coup c'est c'est c'est c'est c'est c'est
du vrai argent sur des non non ça y a
aucun État làdessus le regret que j'ai
de cette de ce qui n'a pas été fait
c'est qu'on s'est pas posé la question
du système qu'on voulait donc on a on a
gardé le même système en mettant du
buffer et des des airbags et cetera donc
c'est oui a des airbags des buffers don
ça il y a pas de problème mais on s'est
pas posé la question de de où on va et
pourquoi faire bah voilà et on revent à
la question du système est-ce qu'on est
capable de s'affranchir du système
friedmanien pour être un peu simpliste
et d'aller vers autre chose et pour
l'instant je ne suis pas sûr si si je
vous offra une baguette magique il y a
qu'en France qu'on pose la question
comme ça c'est de quoi non mais j'aime
bien parce que la baguette magique c'est
aussi on dit si vous si vous étiez Bruno
le mer astrologue
non non non mais c'est c'est c'est c'est
intéressant parce que la la chance que
j'ai eu de vivre dans un environnement
multinational en responsabilité c'est
que les Français ont cette image d'être
ceux qui pensent à la baguette magique
et en gros on dit le français il il a il
prend la Bastille il abolit les
privilèges et il pense qu'il a réinventé
la planète ça c'est parce que vous vous
pensez mal et vous êtes vous êtes
réducteur par rapport au peuple français
on va se le faire différemment non non
mais le Français c'est le coq qui monte
à 5h du matin sur son tas de fumier et
les deux pieds dans la merde quand il
voit le soleil se lever il réveille tout
le monde c'est ça le français oui et et
le français que je suis quand j'habitais
aux États-Unis j'ai rejoint le coneil
administration des amis de Notre-Dame et
avant que Notre-Dame brûle j'avais pris
à mon compte la rénovation du coq de
Notre-Dame donc plus français que moi tu
meurs attention hein faut pas me
provoquer ah bah je suis alsacien et
français
pas mal ça vous a coûté combien la
rénovation du coq euh
plusieurs dizaines de milliers de
dollars
il pas il a pas été rénové puisque
finalement on a mis un uf et le l'Anci
un coque dans une vitrine dans un musée
ça c'est un peu ma frustration
personnelle
ça arrive ça pe comprendre voilà
question internet bonsoir Monsieur Badré
avez-vous le livre avez-vous lu le livre
les veines ouvertes de l'Amérique latine
non car en citant Milton Friedman vous
savez pertinemment que ce n'est pas avec
la bienveillance que la finance mondiale
et les Chicago Boys ont pillé ce
continent ils ont installé des
dictateurs très loin de l'idée que vous
avez d'une gentille utopie du partage
mondial
j'ai pas dit le contraire j'ai alors là
pas il y a pas d'ambigué euh il faut se
remettre la M des années 70 Friedman
inspiration théorique transformation du
du modèle économique en particulier au
Chili pas pas pas pas pas exploité dans
toute l'Amérique latine rôle des
États-Unis de la CIA et cetera moi je
vous parle de l'Amérique latine
d'aujourd'hui qui qui n'est absolument
plus la même euh c'est là que j'investis
c'est c'est très intéressant d'ailleurs
parce que souvent les les
latino-américains ont le sentiment
qu'ils sont le continent oublié et je
leur dis parfois c'est bien qu'on vous
oublie dis c'est le continent qui est
aussi loin de Kiev que de Jérusalem que
de tapé et donc aujourd'hui c'est vrai
qu'alors on voit de manière très visible
le l'espace margentin on voit de manière
très visible Venezuela le Nicaragua le
Salvador et cetera mais la réalité c'est
que la plupart des grands pays
latino-américains sont stables
aujourd'hui ont des alternances
démocratiques dans les deux sens euh des
parlements oui il y a combien
d'inflation
[Musique]
au Chili en Argentine pardon non je dis
mis à part l'Argentine et le Venezuela
ok non c'est ce que je disais non non
vous regardez le le Brésil qui qui était
très décrié
ils ont augmenté les taux d'intérêt
plutôt que nous l'inflation était
contrôlée plusut tôt elle a baissé plus
tôt la croissance était plus forte ENF
le le le cas très intéressant qui qui
est d'ailleurs compliqué à comprendre
pour nous c'est le Pérou le Pérou vous
avez eu six présidents en 6 ans ils sont
tous soit en tôle soit suicidés et
cetera euh mais le la monnaie a pas
bouger la croissance reste forte
l'économie va bien euh c'est quoi les
ressources naturelles du Pérou ah bah le
Pérou est tout une tradition minière
appelez-vous les Espagnols ils ont all
chercher de l'or et de l'argent euh
aujourd'hui ils ont du lithium ils ont
toute une série de minéraux mais il y a
pas que ça c'est ce qui les sauve un peu
quand même les sauve de quoi c'est une
vision de dire ce qui les sauve c'est ça
les sauve pas c'est une économ
oui ben heureusement mais ils ont pas
que ça ils ont aussi de l'agriculture
ils ont des c'est économies qui se
diversifient de plus en plus enfin c'est
c'est ça qui est très intér la Colombie
c'est aussi un c'est a un pays je me
souviens mon premier voyage officiel en
Colombie pour la Banque mondiale je
connaissais pas ce pays j'ai arrivis en
me disant la Colombie c'est d'un côté
les narcoses de l'autre les FARC j'ai
une vision un peu voilà je je je plare
coupable j'avais pas bien regarder mon
dossier je regarde dans l'avion et ca et
je dis je sais plus quelle est
l'autorité que je vois en premier et je
dis B c'est quand même compliqué pays o
il y a des pH qui me dit et vous le fnnc
ça vous empêche de croître ailleurs en
France et il montte sur la carte la
jungle avec les FAR bon il un peu de jeu
mais c'est des pays qui sont qui sont en
train de se transformer c'est des pays
qui sont en train de se transformer et
et c'est intéressant le le le le le le
nouveau président colombien Gustavo
Petro qui est un ancien guerrier rose du
M19 euh
quand il était quand il a été élu la
monnaie s'effondre panique partout et
puis finalement 2 ans plus tard il av
pas la majorité au Parlement donc il est
obligé de en France on naime pas ça
majorité au Parlement c'est un drame
dans tous ces pays il y a aucun
président qui a une majorité au
Parlement et ben ils négocient ils font
un truc qui tient à peu près la route
ils font et donc au total c'est c'est
des économies qui vont plutôt pas mal en
réalité revenons à notre baguette
magique de français ouais
vous voulez quoi comme monde et comment
avec approuvrissement des ressources
fonction exponentielle de consommation
de ressources fonction exponentielle de
production de dette fonction
exponentielle de population
non le le monde que je veux en fait les
objectifs de développement durable aussi
bisonours paraîil c'est plutôt pas mal
si si on a un monde où effectivement
comme dans les objes de développement
durable on diminue la pauvreté de
manière drastique on l'éradique dans les
comme on dit en termes internationaux
combien de milliards pour faire ça
pardon faut combien de milliards pour B
les chiffrages je pas les chiffrages
actualisés mais les chiffrages de
l'époque pour satisfaire l'ensemble des
obje développement durable pardon non
non non je je vous laisse terminer bon
pour satisfaire les objectifs de
développement durable il y avait
plusieurs chiffrages par que c'est c'est
aussi du chiffrage très macro he c'est à
la louche les modèles des Nations Unies
le modèle de la Banque mondiale le
modèle et cetera c'était 4 5000 à 7000 à
7000 8000 par an milliard oui ben
milliards oui bien sûr euh
mais c'est du macro la difficulté donc
j'ai j'avais fait ce rapport from
billions to trillions en disant il nous
faut des trillions donc des milliers de
milliards et ce dont on parle c'est des
centaines alors les gens des centaines
c'est déjà beaucoup entre 100 et 1000 il
faut faire x 10 l'aide publique au
développement aujourd'hui c'est 200
milliards de dollars par an
200 milliards et en plus alors il y a
quelques bizarres il y a une partie de
cette aide qui évidemment maintenant va
en Ukraine et il y a une partie de cette
aide qui reste qui bouge pas du pays
pourquoi parce que quand vous accueillez
accueillez on peut voir mais quand vous
accueillez un réfugié dans dans votre
pays les dépenses que vous consacrez à
dans votre pays compte comme de l'aide
au pays de se réfugier et donc par
exemple les pays scandinaves qui restent
les pays les plus généreux du monde en
terme d'aide en fait il y a une partie
qui reste à Stockholm à Copenhague et à
Oslo et donc les flux nets vers
l'Afrique diminuent sans parler des
effets d'inflation qui fait que la
valeur de cet argent diminue aussi
est-ce que vous pouvez vous faire
l'avocat du diable de de ça le fait que
on laisse que des miettes pour que les
autres se pour pacifier notre terre je
vais pas me faire l'avocat du diable je
dis qu'on avait un déficite de
générosité
est-ce que vous pensez pas que ce
déficit de générosité c'est bien si vous
voulez après avoir des comportements
prédateurs sur d'autres pays parce que
quand même c'est beaucoup plus c'est
beaucoup plus difficile d'aller choper
les ressources d'un pays développé
surtout s'il est armé jusqu'au dents oui
mais je pense que c'est un raisonnement
très courtermiste non non non c'est
encore une fois dans dans un monde en
tableur Excel on peut justifier tout ça
là j'ai aucun moi je pas vent en tableur
Excel ni en Powerpoint
mais ce que je dire par là c'est que je
vous disais tout à l'heure qu'on les
flux privés sont faibles et en baisse
les flux publics sont faibles et en
baisse
et donc on a on a une une difficulté
majeure et pourquoi parce que
aujourd'hui là aussi al pardonnez-moi je
je cite les chiffres de mémoire mais
aujourd'hui on est en gros 500 millions
d'Européens
et la moyenne d'âge je crois que c'est
Nations Unies qui calcule ce chiffre
c'est doit être à peu près 44 ans plus
ou moins en face on a 1 milliard et demi
d'Africains Afrique du Nord comprise et
on doit avoir une moyenne d'âge de
l'ordre de 19 20 ans en 2050 après il y
a des doutes sur la entre 2050 et 2100
il y a plusieurs scénarios mais en gros
en 2050 on sera toujours 500 millions
peut-être un peu moins notre moyenne
d'âge sera passé à 48 49 an aussi on
peut discuterf c'est on vieillit on est
un peu moins nombreux en Europe en
Afrique vous aurez 2 milliards et demi
d'Africains ils auront un peu plus ils
auront peut-être plus 19 ans ils onont
peut-être 20 ou 21 ans de moyenne d'âge
sur un continent qui selon en toute
probabilité sera 30 à 40 % inhabitable
du fait du changement climatique on doit
créer aujourd'hui 3 à 4 millions
d'emplois par mois en Afrique contenu de
la démographie vous croyez qu'on les
crée on va pas créer 3 à 4 millions de
fonctionnaires on faut créer un non mais
il faut il faut il et c'est pas des
mines qui vont créer les emplois vous
parlez des ressources c'est c'est c'est
très bien une mine mais une mine c'est
500 personnes c'est pas c'est pas 4
millions donc il faut créer une économie
qui soit diversifiée une des grosses
difficultés de la plupart des pays
émergents c'est que vous avez un petit
nombre de de de très grandes entreprises
type conglomérat et cetera en général
assez proche des pouvoirs publics et
vous avez une masse de tout petit et
vous avez très peu de choses entre les
deux et c'est ça qu'il faut créer c'est
ça qu'il faut développer et c'est notre
intérêt comme européen c'est pour ça
qu'à courte vue on peut dire
effectivement soyons cyniqu et allons
piller c'est atroce laité c'est que
c'est complètement fou parce que
regardez les tensions sur l'immigration
en Europe mais quand on en sera là si on
n rien fait mais des drames de Lampedusa
ça sera tous les jours
et donc c'est bien le défi auquel on est
confronté donc il faut qu'on
avec ma baguette magique je pense que le
défi du développement durable du
continent africain c'est le défi majeur
pour la planète
c'est en partie parce que vous avez là
aussi ce que j'avais ce que j'avais dit
quand je parlé au ministre des Finances
africain il il y a 2 ans j' dit on vous
a souvent présenté comme le continent
des problèmes vous êtes le continent de
la solution au 21e siècle pourquoi parce
que vous avez des resses dont on a
besoin pour la transition climatique
vous avez la jeunesse vous avez les
emplois vous avez l'imagination
donc ne gâchons pas tout ça pourquoi ils
sont ils sont ils sont au 21e siècle ils
en sont encore dans cet état végétatif
j'espère que vous regrettez
immédiatement ce que vous venez de dire
entendu bon on dirait Nicolas SARC qui
sont pas rentrés dans l'histoire c'est
ça s'appelle se faire l'avocat du diable
non non moi je suis fasciné chaque fois
bien sûr que c'est compliqué ce qui mais
ce qui me fascine aujourd'hui mais la
question est légitime ou pas non elle
est pas légitime parce queelle elle
représente tout un tout un pruride de
colonialisme mal digéré et cetera ENF
c'est insupportable moi j'ai j'ai chaque
fois que je vais c'est vrai en Amérique
latine je veux plus aujourd'hui c'est
vrai en Afrique je connais un peu moins
l'Asie j'ai j'ai une joie de voir
l'enthousiasme de gens moi les les chefs
d'entreprise que j'accompagne dans mon
métier pour réussir à monter une boîte
dans ces pays c'est extraordinaire c'est
des gens qui ont une un courage une
volonté une imagination une
détermination enfin c'est on dit que
c'est compliqué en France de monter une
boîte mais al je va vous dire que dans
ces pays c'est difficile de la faire
grandir et cetera il y a une énergie
extraordinaire enfin pour moi c'est
c'est c'est
je vais exp expliciter un peu m ma
question est-ce que c'est de notre faute
la France Afrique le le françafa
le fait d'avoir mis des dictateurs à
gauche d'avoir mis des dictateurs à
droite est-ce que c'est de notre faute
si l'Afrique est dans cet état là
c'est un débat qu'on peut ouvrir qu'on
refermera jamais c'est dire c'est c'est
relecture de l'histoire
oui bien sûr non non mais j'ai
l'histoire elle est écrite par les
vainqueurs et puis les vainqueurs
changent et cetera mais mon sujet c'est
pas celui-là j'ai pas passé des des
années à me flagéler il y a eu plein
d'erreurs et vous en avez listé une
partie il y a des tas de discussions on
voit bien que c'est c'est c'est pas très
simple et on voit bien qu'aujourd'hui la
France dans un certain nombre de pays
symbolise tout ça
et en même temps il faut qu'on passe à
cette étape du développement durable de
l'Afrique donc on peut on peut épiloguer
sur les raisons et cetera mais ça ne
fait rien avancer si on se concentre moi
ce que je trouve extraordinaire
maintenant qui qui est compliqué pour
nous euh occidentaux pour nous Européens
et pour nous Français c'est qu'on n'est
plus avec les enfants de la
décolonisation on n'est plus avec les
petits- enfants on est avec les arrières
petits- enfants et eux ils ont ils sont
transactionnels hein ils disent euh
voilà je je reviens à ce que je disais
toi tu as un problème avec la Chine et
la Russie pas moi moi j'ai un problème
ici donc on traite mon problème ici et
après je m'occuperai de de Russie et de
Chine avec toi donc c'est pour moi c'est
c'est c'est c'est en pass c'est notre
nouvelle frontière enfin c'est vraiment
euh
est-ce que est-ce c'est pour ça en tout
cas c'est pour pour reprendre ce que je
disais au début c'est c'est à ça que je
consacre ma vie aujourd'hui et pour les
années qui viennent c'est de me dire on
peut faire quelque chose c'est pas de la
charité c'est c'est c'est c'est c'est en
fait on va sauver c'est ça si on les sa
non j'aime pas dire sauver parce que là
aussi on arrive en disant euh
je sauve non on est partenaire on est
partenaire le le le projet qu'on a
développer en Afrique on est 5050 avec
des Africains c'est pas 50 49 et pour
moi c'est très important on est
partenaire on a un intérêt commun à
faire en sorte que ça se passe bien et
on va travailler ensemble c'est pas moi
qui vais te donner des leçons ni toi ça
c'est c'est très important et et et et
moi j'ai énormément de plaisir à
travailler avec ces générations là en
j'ai vraiment des amis dans plein de
pays africains c'est c'est absolument
passionnant de on a on avait créé c'est
c'est complètement là aussi pardon pour
le mot anecdote on avait fait un
une réunion il y a je sais plus en 2016
à Abidjan euh
avec je sais pas si vous connaissez
Estelle yousoufa je demande si vous
l'avez voilà donc estelle avait invité à
Abidjan tous ses de mayottes de mayottes
avait invité à Abidjan tous ses amis
amis de l'Afrique donc il y avait une
partie d'Africains puis une partie
d'occidentaux enfin un peu on s'est
retouvé ah c'est une très belle personne
et on s'est retrouvé à 50 onembrasse on
embrasse elle m'a envoyé un vu pour la
nouvelle année j'ai trouvé ça trop tropp
et donc on s'est retrouvé une
cinquantaine à Abidjan à refaire le
monde il y avait de tout des gens de
toute l'Afrique moi je venais de quitter
la Banque mondiale et cetera et on a
créé un groupe WhatsApp qui s'appelle
les rockstars al je suis désolé je suis
pas sûr que j'ai le droit de discloser
comme on dit ce nom mais c'est amusant
parce que les groupes WhatsApp en
général c'est éphémère des truc qui ça
dure un an ou 6 mois ou 3 jours ce
groupe c'est depuis 2016 ça va faire 8
ans il y a pas une journée où il y a pas
des échanges entre nous mais j'apprends
des tonnes de choses on sait ce qui se
passe passe les nouvelles idées les
trucs ENF c'est extraordinaire il a y a
connaissez maot non malheureusement vous
connaissez les problèmes d'immigration à
Mayotte ouiis benah par Estelle oui ça
je mais je j'ai j'ai une connaissance
interméd je ne suis jamais allé je suis
allé une seule fois à la Réunion en
mission d'inspection des finances donc
c'est c'est la seule connaissance de la
France de l'océan Indien donc vous
connaissez pas mamouzu non je PLA
coupable P Gan non
donc mamouzu on en reparlera les
problèmes d'immigration on en reparlera
j'ai je j'aimerais vous faire réagir à
un commentaire alors c'est pas une
question c'est un commentaire
à propos des agences de notation en 1931
l'agence alors je demande aussi à faire
vérifier ce commentaire donc à propos
des agences de notation en 1931 l'agence
moodies a dégradé la note de la Grèce de
manière spéculative ce qui a provoqué
l'effondrement du pays et l'installation
d'une dictature mis c'est par la suite
excusé c'est possible C épisode plus et
revenons à nos moutons le fond de
garantie des dépôts bancaires
avec effet de levier grâce à Michel
Sapin parce qu'il s'était rendu compte
qu'on avait repéré que le fond de
garantie des dépôts bancaires ne
garantissait que un nombre très très
limité de compte en banque à hauteur de
100000 € en espèce ou que on avait 1
milliard 5 face
et ça fait pas beaucoup hein ça fait un
petit peu short mais short en façon STR
mais maintenant il la garantie des
dépôts s'exerce au niveau européen donc
on a
non mais le j'ai encore une fois j'ai
quitté les banques il y a 12 ans et je
je m'en suis pas réoccupé depuis donc je
vais pas vous donner des chiffres mais
mais les banques ont dû cotiser
plusieurs milliards
je pas en tout cas je sais pas si c'est
par an mais il y a maintenant des
dizaines de milliards qui sont stockés à
à Franfort mais j'ai pas le détail donc
je vais pas faire de commentaires face
en face de combien de en face de combien
de de
de volume d'argent engendré pas engendré
mais paré sur les marchés pas pariier
sur les marchés non c'est pas les les ça
garantit les dépôts des gens c'est pas
les c'est pas l'argent parer sur les
marchés il y a quand même une cohérence
dans la dans dans encore une fois on
peut être critique et je suis le premier
à avoir critiqué l'insuffisance des
rform pardon l'insuffisance des réformes
qu'on a fait après la crise financière
mais il y a une cohérence entre
renforcer le capital des banques
renforcer leur liquidité leur interdire
de spéculer sur leurs fonds propres et
ce tout ça ça a été fait et donc là on
parle de de garantir de le le les dépôts
du client de la Caisse régionale du
Crédit agcole de la caisse départ la
Société Générale enfin c'est pas on
n'est pas en train de garantir les
opérations de marché de tel ou telle
banque c'est pas les faut faut pas faut
pas mélanger tout enfin c'est donc je
mélange pas tout et donc ce fond garanti
des dépôts bancaires quand Michel Sapin
s'était rendu compte que bah ça faisait
un petit peu chip il a dit ne vous
inquiétez pas on fera un effet de levier
dessus la France s'engagera et oui mais
honnêtement je je me souviens plus de
cet épisode ce que je sais c'est que
c'est devenu un sujet européen c'est
plus un sujet français et donc
effectivement l'assurance est pas plus
la population est grande plus le risque
ENF voilà on est quand même parce que je
suis totalement détendu peut-être pas
mais je pense qu'on a encore une fois je
ce que je disais tout à l'heure je pense
que sur le on a renforcé le système tel
qu'il était on n pas repensé le système
vous avez remaquillé la vieille quoi là
vous l'avez déjà dit non on l'a pas
remaquillé on l'a renforcéi on pe lui
dire on lui a mis des genouillères on
lui a mis un exoquelette on lui a mis je
sais pas quoi mais on n pas on l'a pas
rajeuni quoi en on l'a pas transformé on
n pas on n pas eu baguette magique pour
faire de la vieille sor une jeune fée
c'est c'est vilain de comparer avec une
vieille sorcière parlons de l'Irak donc
vous aviez vos bureaux juste à côté de
la cellule diplomatique dans la cellule
diplomatique dans la cellule
diplomatique pourquoi pourquoi dans la
cellule diplomatique c'est le hasard oui
parce que j' c'est là qu' avait de la
place alors pas complètement parce qu'en
fait euh
la la petite histoire et que
pendant que j'étais à New York j'avais
été rappelé je j'ai évoqué Michel Cansu
qui est vraiment le une des personnes
qui m'a qui m'a inspiré
professionnellement m'avait demandé de
travailler avec lui sur la question du
financement d'accès à l'eau euau
et donc tout en étant chez Lazar je
travaillais avec lui et c'est vrai que
c'est la première fois de ma vie que je
m'intéressais à une question qui est
extraordinairement complexe qui est
l'eau l'eau c'est à la fois le le sujet
mondial par excellence le cycle de l'eau
en gr depuis la création de la terre H2O
alors c'est parfois sous forme de glace
parfois sous forme de vapeur parfois
sous forme de liquide vous connaissez la
voisier oui ben c'est je le cité dans le
livre qu'on a fait qui s'appelle eau euh
donc en gros c'est un problème mondial
le cycle de l'eau il est mondial l'eau
qui s'évapore ici on sait pas où elle va
retomber enfin et cetera et en même
temps elle se gère localement c'est pas
il y a pas d'autorité mondiale de l'eau
il y en aura pas pourquoi parce que
l'eau c'est que c'est c'est c'est
quelque chose que je gère par bassin
versant en France on a l' enfin je
comment ça s'appelle l'utorité de bassin
non pas pas je sais plus for en tout cas
pour la scène pour le rein mais la
Tennessee Valley Authority de de
Franklin Roosevelt aux États-Unis la TVA
et cetera et donc l'eau c'est un
problème qui se gère localement dans une
perspective mondiale et qui est un sujet
très compliqué parce que pour le coup on
parlait de religion tout à l'heure dans
toutes les religions
l'eau c'est en général l'endroit où ça a
commencé et donc c'est il y a une
relation au sacré et une relation à la
vie et donc dans l'esprit des gens l'eau
faut pas y toucher c'est gratuit ça
c'est un don de Dieu quel que soit le
nom qu'on met derrière Luu et pourant
euh bah il faut quand même payer quoi
donc on avait enfin on avait cette
formule en disant oui Dieu a pensé à
donner à l'eau mais il a oublié de
mettre les tuyaux donc en fait on vous
demande pas de payer l'eau on vous
demande de payer les on vous demande de
payer les tuyaux
et donc je travaille avec avec Michel
qu'essu sur l'eau Jacques cherac est
réélu face à Jean-Marie Le Pen dans les
circonstances qu'on sait à l'époque et
c'était après son discours de
Johannesburg la planète brûle on regarde
ailleurs enfin donc le moment où il
pousse sur ses ces sujetslà euh il
demande à Michel Cansu de venir
travailler avec lui l'Élysée Michel Canu
dit j'ai pris ma retraite je veux pas
travailler je veux bien travailler avec
vous mais en fait voilà enfin je veux
bien vous donner un conseil mais
recruter le le Bertrand qui travaille
avec moi euh pour parce que la France
présidit le sommet du G8 al il était
éviant c'est pour ça qu'on parlait d'eau
mais enfin bon euh et donc il y avait
pas le directeur de nestley le PDG de
nestley qui avait dit des truc sur la
flotte non en aujourd'hui oui à l'époque
je sais plus mais et donc voilà donc je
et et donc je je viens travailler à
l'Élysée sur ces questions de
développement durable d'eau et par
extension les nouvelle nouvelle approche
de la relation africaine et cetera et
donc c'était pas idiot que je sois après
la cellule diplomatique voilà donc
c'était pas
mais c'est vrai que c'était étonnant
parce que je suis arrivé j'ai arrivé des
États-Unis euh
à Paris en janvier 2003 ENF faut se
rappeler le paroxisme de crise entre les
deux pays c'était le moment où Jacques
shirac réunissait Schroder et Poutine à
Paris
pour s'opposer aux États-Unis enfin
c'était c'était pas très simple donc mes
copains américains me disaient tu es un
salot es et cetera il faut évidemment
attaquer l'Irak et avec les Français et
pour les Français je venais des
États-Unis donc j'étais un peu entre
deux quand vous étiez aux États-Unis
est-ce que les Américains ont essayé de
vous tamponner un peu de Me tamponner
c'està-dire est-ce que les services
secrets américains ont essayer de vous
recruter ah non est-ce que les services
français ont essayé de vous recruter
même pas
non ça m'aurait amusé parce que j'avais
eu unje non non j'avais eu un cours
j'avais eu un cours à à CHUS en dernière
année je sais plus com il s'appel de
géopolitique où le prof nous disait vous
êtes descies vous allez être approché
donc on on était tous très excités s'app
Patrick l matre et on était tous très
excités et en fait non j'ai jamais eu
AFF faire je je connaissais à titre
personnel et amical Bernard mier qui
vient de quitté la DGSE mais c'est à peu
près le seul contact que j'ai jamais eu
en tout cas il a quitté la DGSE ou il
s'est fait virer il est plus il est à la
retraite maintenant ah ouais et
la seule fois je me souviens quand au
sommet du G8 desvant donc c'était la
première fois que je me retrouvais dans
un sommet international et euh et donc
vous saz on est dans une bulle avec des
sécurité partout et avec des passes qui
vous permettent d'aller aux différents
endroits et je me souviens c'était
j'avais fait une remarque assez naïve à
l'époque j'avais serré la main de
Poutine comme tous les chefs d'État au
moment ils arrivent on serre les mains
et j'avais dit c'est comment je me
souviens plus mais jeavais trouvé très
petit je moi je suis grand mais j'avais
très petit je et et je je me tourne vers
un un de mes collègues un peu plus
ancien JEI dit je crois que c'est la
première fois que je ser la main d'un
agent du KGB il me dit c'est ce que tu
crois j'avais trouvé ça c'était lunaire
comme blague on on était dans une sur la
terrasse de l'hôtel des viands et il y
avait effectivement tous les chefs
d'État je faisais cette blague nulle il
me répond voilà
c'était mon entrée dans le monde
international et c'est pas mal quand
même non c'était bien he c'était bien
alors ce qui est amusant c'est qu'après
j'ai reparticipé à un G20 en Australie
en 2014
et là le le Premier ministre australien
de l'époque qui s'appelait Tony Abot
reçoit tous les chefs d'État donc il y
avait une espèce de de salle avant la la
salle plainère c'est la grande table
ronde où les gens se mettent autour il y
a comme à eviant il y a l'heure et demi
où les les chefs d'État se retrouve avec
chacun leur entourage et puis discute en
c'est très c'est très informel et et
Tony Abot avait trouvé amusant de
prendre un koala et de mettre de koala
dans les bras des gens et en fait ce qui
était très c'est que tous ces chefs
d'État donc il y avait modi Poutine
Obama et cetera avecune frousse et que
le koala pisse leur costume vous mettez
ce koala il va faire pipi sur Mo voilà
comme ça ça Perm de dramatiser les G20
il y a aussi ce genre d'épisode plus
est-ce que vous pouvez me parler des
Young leader euh des young leaders oui
euh moi j'ai j'ai fait plusieurs
programmes de Young leader je ne suis
plus young ni leader mais enfin en tout
cas
je peux y croire j'ai des badge dans
celui qui est le le plus connu en France
c'est celui de la French American
Foundation en français c'est comment
Fondation franco-américaine qui était en
fait une fondation qui a été créée par
valériecardestin et Géral Ford ils ont
toujours leur siège à côté de
l'ambassade d'Allemagne
je sais pas c'est une bon question je
sais pas je devrais savoir je sais pas
et donc Ford des giscar créé pour
célébrer le bicentenaire de
l'indépendance américaine en 1976 donc
200 ans après déclaration de 1776 une
fondation pour rapprocher les les deux
pays et cette fondation en fait elle est
connue par son programme de young
leaders mais elle a beaucoup d'autres
activités en fait c'est une fondation
qui qui a toute une série de d'activités
de rapprochement il y a un prix de
traduction par exemple il a des
référence à la cybersécuritéas de truc
mais c'est vrai que le programme phare
qui était alors aujourd'hui il y a
beaucoup de gens qui ont qui ont fait
des programmes équivalents mais c'était
le premier àépoque était de dire on va
faire des young leaders donc chaque
année ça dire quoi young leaders euh
des jeunes qui ont un potentiel avoir
des positions de leadership dans la
société euh et donc chaque année on va
sélectionner je combien ça été entre
entre 7 et 10 français et 7 et 10
américains qu'on va mettre ensemble
plusieurs jours un coup en France un
coup aux États-Unis pour développer des
liens entre les leadership des des deux
pays ce que je trouve une très très
bonne idée vraiment
alors depuis ça a sé maintenant il y a
une fondation alors il y avait une idée
de fondation franco-russe qui pour des
raisons évidentes n'a pas vu le jour il
y a une fondation franco-chinoise une
fondation franco-indienne une fondation
franco-africaine une fondation c'est un
modèle qui a vraiment été répliqué qui a
vraiment été beaucoup répliqué al pour
la petite histoire moi j'ai été
sélectionné quand j'habitais New York et
c'est les Américains qui m'ont proposé
donc je suis français mais j'ai pas été
proposé par les Français j'étais proposé
par les Américains et donc j'ai fait le
programme en 2002 2003 est-ce que
connaissez la Commission Trilatérale de
nom mais pas plus que ça non question
internet comment peut-il être croyant et
pratiquer l'usure pointinrogation en
sachant que le christianisme s'est
opposé à celui-ci
alors je pratique pas l'usure parce que
je suis pas banquier euh
et c'est pour ça que quand vous me posez
la question tout à l'heure euh
je mets pas ma foi en bandoulière parce
que ma foi elle me crée plus de soucis
que de elle m'apporte des réponses mais
en même temps elle voilà elle me
confronte au réel tous les jours c'est
pas facile c'est pas la Bible comme
l'Évangile c'est pas c'est pas un livre
de recette qui vous donne ce qu'il faut
faire matin midi et soir moi c'est plus
une source d'interrogation et une source
d'inspiration donc dire que parce que je
suis chrétien
pour ça je le dis pas trop parce que ça
ça me donne encore une fois ni un batch
de respectabilité ni une recette ni quoi
que ce soit donc j'ai toujours fait très
attention dans tous mes Jobs en fait
j'ai été euh enfin je l'ai dit je je ne
m'en suis pas caché mais j'ai pas fait
de prosélitisme la la seule fois où ça a
été un peu plus visible et c'était c'est
une anecdote encore une fois pardon
amusante c'est quand j'ai sorti mon
dernier livre voulons-nous sérieusement
changer le monde le point vous voulais
faire mon portrait
et j'habitais encore aux États-Unis à
l'époque je devais repartir aux
États-Unis et ils me disent on a qu'à se
retrouver au Bonapart qui est la la
brasserie en face de Saint-Germain des
prê peu importe on fait l'interview euh
et puis il pleuvait des cordes enfin
c'était un déluge très très sombre et
lumière blafarde des néons dans le truc
et le photographe dit je peux pas
prendre une photo là c'est horrible il
faut qu'on aille ailleurs et puis on
regarde ailleurs puis moi j'ai j'ai mon
avion enfin je on peut pas et puis on va
aller dans l'église et donc on traverse
en courant la la place devant l'église
Saint-Germain des fr on rentre dans
l'église qui était ouverte là je tombe
mon impère mon truc enfin je ruisse les
dos quoi je m'assois sur une chaise et
le pH dit ne bougez plus il prend une
photo il dit c'est bon bon très bien et
effectivement quand le portrait sort on
voit une photo où je suis assis sur une
chaise d'église où on a l'impression que
je vois la Vierge il y a une espèce de
rayon de lumière et ils ont titré
bertrambadr apôtre de la finance verte
évidemment le journaliste a tiré la
métaphore dans tout l'article en disant
sa foi et cetera donc à partir de là
c'est devenu un peu publque mais bon je
encore une fois je je l'assume mais j'en
fais pas une source de proséitisme c'est
pour moi c'est c'est c'est pas une
fierté c'est c'est une exigence vraiment
c'est
qu'est-ce que vous pensez des luutériens
en terme d'exigigen
c'est je sa pas je peux pas comparer
après
c'est je sais pas très bien comment vous
répondre à cette question je suis pas
sûr qu'il soit plus ou moins exigeant je
dans la finance ouais on peut recycler
weberthique
je suis pas sûr que ça soit vérifié en
réalité c'est une histoire assez facile
à raconter je suis pas sûr qu'elle soit
si exacte que ça que les protestants
étaient plus destinés à faire tel ou tel
métier les catholiques tel j'en sais
rien
question Internet et l'évasion fiscale
dans tout ça pour interrogation
bah c'est un sujet c'est c'est un énorme
problème alors moi aujourd'hui il se
trouve que et ça je vous le recommande
si vous voulezinroger pour pour Serview
j'ai retrouver quand j'étais à la Banque
mondiale
un ami qui était étudiant avec moi que
j'avais perdu de vue qui s'appelle
Pascal Saint-Amant je sais pas si vous
voyez qui c'est alors Pascal saintamand
c'est la personne qui a l'OCDE
donc il était il était au ministère des
Finances en France il s'occupé de
fiscalité et il est parti au département
fiscal de l'OCDE il y a 15 ans qui est
un département pas très intéressant et
c'est lui qui était non non non ce c'est
pas du tout le sujet et et et c'est lui
qui a était à l'origine avec le le
secrétaire général de l'époque André
legoura de tout ce qui a étéit taxation
minimum transfert d'information et
cetera
donc il il a tapé dans le dur il est
allé alors c'est évidemment pas parfait
mais s'il y a quelque chose qui a évolué
c'est bien ça depuis 15 ans vous avez
des échanges automatique d'information
d'un pays à l'autre une des raisons pour
lesquelles j'ai rendu ma carte verte
c'est que c'était infernal à chaque fois
que je faisais je bougé 1 € fallait je
remplisse un formulaire pour dire je
l'avais changé de tel compte et cetera
donc on on a changé de monde quand même
alors est-ce que ça a disparu la réponse
évidemment non
mais aujourd'hui on publie sans aucune
gêne des listes de pays dans lesquels on
peut investir pas investir les pays qui
se comportent bien et cetera c'est un
moi moi comme investisseur tous les mois
on on reçoit les listes de l'OCDE de
l'Europe disant vous pouvez pas aller
dans ce pays dans ce pays et cetera donc
encore une fois on n pas résolu la
question mais la question elle est sur
la table elle est de moins en moins
supportée donc encore une fois elle a
pas disparu mais je pense qu'elle a
quand même
aujourd'hui on a mis en place des outils
qui nous permettent de commencer dans la
bonne direction alors je suis prudent
parce que c'est c'est un sujet aussi
vieux que le monde euh
c'est vrai que après la crise financière
vous souz peut-être de l'enthousiasme de
Nicolas Sarkozi qui avait dit ça y est
on a tout est sur la table on a tout
réglé y compris les paradis fiscaux bon
CIT un peu excessif mais mais c'est vrai
que regardez un pays comme la Suisse
c'est un vrai vrai changement en 20 ans
ils ont plus le droit de démarcher des
gens en France c'est ça bah par exemple
non mais il a d'autres choses encore une
fois il y a des règles ENF c'est
est-ce que c'est suffisant non mais
est-ce que ça va dans la bonne direction
oui
Bruno Le Maire pour vous c'est un bon
ministre des Finances plutôt oui
pourquoi euh d'abord rassure
non je suis pas sûr que ça soit ça soit
le ça soit le sujet mais c'est c'est il
a des dones de vin et d'astrologue non
c'est pas ce qu'on lui demande
d'ailleurs quand quand il dit que
trivialement il pense qu'on est à la
veille des 30 glorieuses en France en
c'est qu'il fait pas de prospective
ah il fait de la politique donc la
politique c'est comm devant les
astrologues c'est ça la politique c'est
comme les devin et les astrologues bon
il y a il y a une partie oui un peu
d'adhérence oui
il faut vendre il faut vendre un avenir
meilleur non non je pense que d'abord le
fait qu'il a duré dans le poste c'était
bien parce qu'il faut se rappeler
pendant des années ça changé tous les
ans donc d'avoir un peu de durée
d'avoir un peu de la continuité dans les
relations internationales ENF c'est des
sujets sur lesquels qu'il a alors
c'était pas son terrain de chasse
naturel il venait pas de là et qui s il
a plutôt bien habité la fonction
question internet faut-il taxer les
transactions financières
B elles sont déjà taxées genre une taxe
tobine alors je vais vous raconter une
autre histoire je vais pas dire anecdote
cette fois mais c'est c'est une c'est
une histoire euh qui date de mon passage
à l'Élysée avant le sommet du G8 de 2003
il y avait une tradition qui avait été
installée je suis plus quel chef d'État
avant de réunir de faire trois grandes
conférences à l'Élysée avec le patronat
les syndicats et la société civile donc
donc Jacques Chirac réunit la sociéé les
ONG et je me souviens il fait cette
réunion avec les ONG le 30 avril 2003 je
me s que c'est le 30 avril parce que
c'était la veille du 1er mai c'est un
truisme et que la réunion doit être à
16h l'après-midi et que à partir de 18h
les gens seent les monsieur le Président
je suis désolé j'ai mon train j'ai mon
avion je dois par f il y avait un côté
surréel on voyait le président présider
une réunion dont les gens partaient
petit à petit et à cette réunion de la
société civile vous aviez euh Amnesy
internationale Greenpeace Oxfam Médecin
du Monde enfin tout toutes toutes les
grandes associations les derniers à
parler c'est attaque je sais pas si vous
vous souvenez d'attaque euh qui tt
d'attaque c'est la tax tobine attaque
sur les transactions financières le
représentant d'attaque dit monsieur le
Président vous connaissez le programme
d'attaque nous il faut faire une taxe
sur les transactions financières pour
euh éradiquer la pauvreté dans le monde
cette taxe rapporterait 1000 milliards
qu'on all louré à l'Afrique et fin de la
pauvreté en Afrique B Chirac fait du
Chirac et dit écoutez formidable écoutez
je crois que James stin sur son ligne
mort a dit que cette idée ne marchait
pas donc voilà mais en même temps vous
posez une bonne question et donc je vais
demander à mes équipes avant qu'on
arrête cette réunion de réfléchir à
cette question et on revient vers vous
et évidemment vous ferez partie de la
réflexion bon la Réunion s'achève et là
dans la grande tradition le président se
tourne vers Maurice gourd monontagne et
son cher pas en disant Maurice à vous de
jouer Maurice se tourne vers Jérôme
bonafond qui était le le conseiller sur
les questions mondial et cetera avec qui
je travaillais et Jérôme se tourne vers
moi il dit bah écoute on va aller
déjeuner demain on va voir ce qu'on fait
et en fait on a créé un groupe qu'on a
appelé on voulait pas appeler mot
taxation parce qu'aux États-Unis vous
n'avez pas le droit de parler de
taxation internationale c'est interdit
par le Congrès donc si vous mettez le
mot taxation fin d'histoire tout de
suite on a appelé ça groupe de réflexion
sur les nouvelles contributions
financières internationales on a créé ce
ce groupe dont la présidence a été
confié à Jean-Pierre landandoau qui
était qui qui après été sous-gouverneur
de la Banque de France et on a fait
pendant un an on a travailler sur ce que
pourrait être une taxe pour financer le
développement cétait complètement
révolutionnaire il y avait personne qui
avait fait ça à l'époque avec le gar
d'attaque mais il y avait le meddeef il
y avait le FMI il y avait le patron il y
avait lafd des économistes oxfemme fait
un groupe on était une vingtaine
première réunion tout le monde était
contre en tout il y avait pas d'avis
et en fait en travaillant petit à petit
on a fait une conférence de presse à la
fin où tout le monde était sur C disant
on est d'accord et c'est là qu'on a créé
la taxe sur les billets d'avion qui qui
permet de financer la recherche médicale
et en fait la vision de shirac vraiment
j'étais très très confortable avec cette
idée c'était de dire au fond de même
qu'on a fait nation autour du Parlement
et de l'impôt il faut qu'on fasse
mondialisation en partageant des
ressources et il faut qu'on trouve des
ressources mondiales qui servent à la
mondialisation sinon
ça va ça va très mal se finir et donc on
avait regardé un certain nombre
d'hypothèses alors il y avait du
problème on va taxer les ventes d'armes
alors en fait c'est une fausse bonne
idée parce qu'en fait il y a pas tant de
vente d'armes que ça enfin à l'époque
j'ai plus à l'époque les chiffres
c'était 60 ou 80 milliards de dollars
par an c'est probement un peu plus
aujourd'hui mais même mondialement oui
euh c'est probblement un peu plus aui
mais à l'époque c'était ça les es de
grandeur pour pour lever l'argent dont
on parlait il fallait mettre des taux
d'imposition sur des ventes d'armes très
élevées et puis allit demander aux
Russes au chinois s'il voulait accepter
qu'on taxe vent d'armes donc c'est était
mort il y avait des idées aussi comme on
va faire une loterie internationale et
on va mettre un peu comme le loterie du
patrimoine mais on fait une loterie pour
l'Afrique ENF bref pas mal d'idées il y
avait une idée que moi je trouvais très
très bien qui était qui revient
d'ailleurs un peu aujourd'hui sur le
transport maritime parce que le
transport maritime partage avec le
transport aérien le fait qu'il n'ont pas
de taxe sur leur carburant
alors le transport maritime la réflexion
qu'on avait c'est dire c'est assez
simple il y a des D3 le D3 du pas
decalis les D3 indonésiens où les
bateaux passent il suffit de mettre un
satellite au-dessus
et on dit bah la pompe bah tu tu es
passé par là c'est 5000 dollars point tu
payes des 5000 dollars et si tu veux pas
bah tu fais le tour par l'Écosse et
l'Écosse ça te prend de jours et donc
comme ça prend qu'une journée ben on
calcule le coût et on fait un truc qui
fait que tu as plutôt quand même
continuer intérêt à passer par la p de
calé et al là les juristes m'ont dit
mais c'est pas possible parce qu'en fait
le droit international c'est d'abord un
droit de la mer et donc si on commence à
mettre des contraintes sur le trajet des
bateaux lié à des prix c'est dangereux
de même queune des raisons pour
lesquelles les avions ne payent pas de
taxes sur le kérosè c'est pour pas qu'il
a de l'optimisation antisécuritaire
c'est je vais aller faire le plein plus
loin
comment avec votre voiture on peut pas
se permettre qu'un avion tombe en panne
parce qu'il a pas voulu aller prendre de
l'essence à un endroit il a voulu aller
chercher bref donc il y a état de raison
mais ça date il y a longtemps et donc on
a on a abouti sur la donc on n'est pas
revenu sur la taxe sur les transactions
financières qui a vu le jour un peu plus
tard mais on a fait cette taxe sur les
billets d'avion et je continue à penser
que c'est une très bonne idée et c'est
une idée qui a été remise au goût du
jour au sommet que organisé Emmanuel
Macron à Paris le l'été dernier sur le
nouveau pacte financier mondial on a
relancé les réflexions sur une taxe sur
le transport maritime ou sur d'autres
d'autres système de taxes je pense qu'il
faut trouver des ressources mondiales
qui n'existent pas les nations- Unies
c'est c'est du don volontaire il il y a
pas de mécanique automatique he
question internet que pensent-t-il du
rapport mi12 de 1973 du rapport Mi-1 ah
de de mes 72 ah oui le rapport du Club
de Rome oui pour moi c'est c'est c'est
pour pour ça que je trouve ça très
intéressant j'aurais pu le mentionner
tout à l'heure 70 71 72 70 Friedman 71
Nixon 72 midos le Club de Rome qui pose
la question assez simple qu'on peut pas
croître de manière infinie dans un monde
fini et ce qui est très intéressant
c'est que le débat qu'on a ce soir il
porte sur ces trois questions quel est
le rôle de l'entreprise et du profit à
quoi sert le marché et la confiance Fiat
money est-ce qu'on peut croître de
manière finie de manière infinie dans un
monde fini et en en 2024 on pose des
alors on a un peu sophistiqué mais c'est
exactement le débat dans lequel on est
ce soir
question internet que pense votre invité
dans notre invité que pense l'invité de
la politique ultralibérale de jaavier My
serait-elle applicable en France
alors euh
c'est une très bonne question applicable
en France c'est pas c'est c'est
évidemment non et c'est pas pertinent la
France a pas 150 % d'inflation n' pas 50
% de la population dessous du seuil de
pauv é n'est pas en programme FMI et
cetera c'est pas la comparaison n'est
pas ne vaut pas euh
le le le Camil il est très intéressant
parce que évidemment il représente
la plupart des choses auxquelles en tant
que citoyen croyant en démocratie
je n'aime pas donc il y a pas de en même
temps quand on regarde ce qui est devenu
l'Argentine qui pour moi est est un
mystère éternel j'adore ce pays c'est un
des plus beau pays du monde les gens
sont sympas pardon vous avez été où B
j'ai été à la fois en voyage officiel
j'été à buenoser j'aiété enfin au SHUa
et dans le sud en Patagonie enfin
j'aiétaé vraiment c'est un pays que
j'aime beaucoup vous avez été à Salta
non non j'ai pas été à Salta c'est un de
mes regrets j'espère que j'aurai
l'occasion de donc en tout casargentine
j'aime beaucoup y aller notre fond a
choisi de ne pas investir en Argentine
c'est un pays très compliqué mon maître
toujours Michel Canu patron du FMI
m'avait dit le Club de Paris qui est le
club qui réunit les États qui prêtent au
pays et qui quandti un problème de dette
restructure la dette le Club de Paris a
été créé en 1956 pour l'Argentine et
l'Argentine restera son fond de commerce
pour toujours c'est un pays qui regorge
de richesse mais dont la dont les élites
ont jamais réussi à trouver un modèle
qui fonctionne donc ça a fonctionné au
début du 20e siècle c'était comme on dit
souvent la 6e ou 7e économie mondiale
euh et donc
la succession des présidents qui ont
juste perpétué le système avec une
corruption très très importante euh
c'est pas possible le message de mil
c'est dire il faut passer à autre chose
alors il dolllarisation c'est juste
impossible on peut rentrer dans le
détail technique mais en tout cas ce qui
est intéressant
c'est que il met le doigt là où ça fait
mal qui est toutes les des arrangements
réglementaires toute une série de choses
il obtiendra pas forcément satisfaction
surtout mais en tout cas il donne
peut-être le coup de pied qui fait qu'on
va sortir d'un système qui qui est
verérolé depuis 80 ans quoi c'est donc
est-ce que c'est la solution je ne sais
pas mais en tout cas
IR ront avec le cours précédent et ce
qui est intéressant c'est que le FMI qui
n'est pas aujourd'hui le FMI tel qu'on
imagine il y a 40 ou 50 ans
le soutien donc en tout CASF
il ne représente pas ce que ce que le
type de dirigeant auquel je crois mais
je pense que c'est les les mesures qu'il
propos en tout cas en partie vont dans
la bonne direction
Davos pouvez nous en dire un peu plus
pas allé là jamais ah si pas jamais mais
non j'y suis allé quand j'étais
dirigeant de la Banque mondiale parce
qu'on était on était invité euh j'y suis
allé donc un certain nombre de fois
avant le covid j'y suis pas retourné
depuis
je pense que c'est comme Surel la
formule ça ne mérite ni cet excès
d'honneur ni tant d' digité je pense que
c'est un lieu euh
d'une certaine manière c'est
probablement un lieu de cette époque
un lieu où les élites se parlent et
cetera euh je veux pas cracher dans la
soupe j'étais très heureux d'y aller
j'ai rencontré des tas de gens vraiment
j'ai j'ai eu des idées et cetera en même
temps le livre voulons-nous sérieusement
changer le monde il a germé là-bas le
sérieusement il vient de là-bas
c'est-à-dire que à la fin de Davos en
rentrant je discutais avec un avec un de
mes amis qui était aussi et je lui dis
c'est super on va à Davos et tous les
problèmes du monde sont réglés et puis
on vient à l'année suivante et on
reprend la feuille donc on n'est pas
sérieux et et donc peut-être qu'il faut
un endroit où les gens se parlent ça
c'est bien euh mais je suis pas sûr que
ça soit là que ça se passe en réalité
pour la suite donc voilà je pas de
j'assume d' être aller j'y vais plus
voilà c'est comme ça il y a pas une
histoire bon non notre truc de non bon
vous avez trois livres à à conseiller à
notre communauté
ou là j'ai j'ai comme je dis je lis un
livre par jour quand je peux euh
un livre par jour ça fait beaucoup quand
même mais pas par ENF oui j'essaie je
lis beaucoup beaucoup je c images des
Gour où j'en lis plusieurs vous lisez
quoi en ce moment je viens de finir le
prix concours
je viens de finir un livre al c'est un
romanci mais c'est pas ce que je
recommanderais mais posz la question
c'est un romancier britannique s'appelle
Robert Harris je sais pas si vous
connaissez
qui prend enfin c'est des romans
historiques et
il a son son son il a fait une trilogie
où il se met à la place de l'esclave là
va franchi de Cicéron qui raconte la vie
de Cicéron c'est extraordinaire vous
revivez Cicéron pompé César enfin c'est
et là celui que je viens de lire c'est
sur la période de Cromwell donc ça j'ai
j'ai lu ça j'essaie toujours de lire en
acclairance un livre en anglais un livre
en français donc là je suis plus dans
une phase roman en ce moment j'ai plutôt
lu des romans si je dois recommander
trois livres il y en a un que je mets
au-dessus de tout euh qui est la
recherche du temps perdu alors je le
fais pas par snobisme euh là aussi c'est
la manière dont j'ai découvert la
recherche euh c'est j'ai j'ai une une
mère qui est professeur de français il
m'a toujours fait beaucoup lire je pense
que ça vient de là j'ai une famille a
plein de livres à la maison papa il
faisait quoi pardon papa il faisait quoi
euh il était fonctionnaire pu après il
il a été il a fait la politique dans
deème partie de sa vie et et ma mère
m'avaitement non il était sénateur non
il était sénateur mère de VI laavraiee
ou en 92 en 92 et et donc
ma mère m'offre pour mes 20 temps dans
la collection bouquin la recherche du
temps perdu cel je dois partir pour en
stage d'école et je pars à Hong Kong et
en Chine très très loin à l'époque on en
plus je l' voyais par nouvelle frontière
Bruxell ENF j'avais pris un billet qui
coûtait rien mais j'ai mis 3 jours pour
aller là-bas et je me suis dit bon la
recherche du temps perdu soit je le mets
dans la bibliothèque et je regarde pour
toujours soit je ne prends que ce livre
il y a pas de tablette à l'époque donc
et je me disais bouquin c'est bien parce
qu'il y a beaucoup de textes et cetera
donc j'ai pris la recherche du temps
perdu et pendant un mois j'ai regardé ça
bibliothèque à Hong Kong et puis après
dis bon allez on attaque et j'ai plongé
dedans et
j'ai visité avec un de mes amis la Chine
en train je lisais la recherche du temps
perdu j'ai et je suis tombé arrê dingue
de ce livre je trouvais profond drôle
bien écrit ENF ça m'a ouvert un univers
extraordinaire
combien d'années plus tard je veux pas
dire de bêtises 12 ans plus tard je l'ai
relu
et c'est d'ailleurs pour ça que notre
troisième fille s'appelle Orian en
hommage à Oriane de guerm que c'est dans
le sourire pleuvait
donc pour moi prus c'est c'est
indépassable c'est vraiment dans la
littérature le le le le livre et et et
de manière amusante quand on était aux
États-Unis pendant le covid on montait
le samedi on faisait une réunion avec
des amis américains des AM français et
on lisait post vraiment c'était
euh donc ça c'est voilà ça c'est un
livre que que je recommanderais je suis
un très grand fan de bande dessinée
alors je sais pas si c'est un livre que
je recommanderai mais c'est en tout cas
moi c'est important et une bande
dessinée qui est une des premières que
j'ai lu c'est Blueberry le lieutenant de
de l'armée de la cavalerie américaine
je pense que c'est de là que vient mon
mon goût des États-Unis et Blueberry il
y a pour les spécialiste il y en a deux
qui sont au-dessus de tout c'est la mine
de l'allemand perdu le spectre bal d'or
c'est extraordinaire c'est le
dessinateur Gira au sommet de son art
l'histoire exceptionnel le dessin est
dingue je suis devenu fou amoureux de
l'Ouest américain et donc Blueberry dans
la série finit sa vie à tomstone Arizona
et pour la petite histoire encore une
fois
à la fin de mon premier séjour américain
j'ai voulu aller à Tombstone il faut y
aller c'est à la frontière mexicaine au
sud de l'Arizona et cetera et
et donc chaque jour Tombstone c'est
aussi la ville de duel à hoque cororal
donc tous les jours il rejoue duel à Ho
Coral c'est l'attraction de Tombstone
qui une espèce de village fantôme dans
l'Arizona il y avait une mine d'argent
ça marcher pendant 20 ans ça a fermé
mais il reste le village et donc on y va
et donc c'était pour toute ma famille
c'était quand même beaucoup de
kilomètres pour aller à Tombstone et et
ma femme dit au gars qui jouait le donc
le duel ho Coral c'est c'est W her
docolid les Clanton les ory et cetera
vous avez encore les tombes de ces
gens-l au cimetière de Tombstone
d'ailleurs c'est c'est ça sent le le
vrai et donc ma femme dit écoutez on a
fait 5000 km faire plaisir à mon mari
donnez-liui un truc qu'on n revienne pas
et le gars me donne son étoile de
Marshall US Marshall Tombstone que j'ai
gardé sur ma table de Chevé depuis 20
ans et ça c'est Blueberry et ça ça pour
moi c'est c'est c'est un souvenir
extrêmement fort et al il y a une suite
je vais pour la Banque mondiale à Kabou
en 2014 et dans l'avion de retour Kabou
très corr plus je vois le président et
cetera et je me retrouve dans l'avion à
côté de John McCain
que je reconnais quand même parce que ou
est petit oui mais en il a un physique
quand même assz remarquable donc je suis
assis à côté de lui en fait le siège à
côté de John McCain donc au début je je
pas l'emmerder et puis quand même il a
côté people quoi je regardé et et je lui
dis you senateur MC dit oui oui bon
sénateur MC et alors on commence à
parler un peu d'Afghanistan il faisait
une mission du Sénat américain sur la
corruption il me dit c'est horrible je
dis oui c'est horrible enfin bon on
revient quand même plutôt pas
enthousiasmé par ce qu'on avait vu puis
au bout d'un quart d'heure d'Afghanistan
je lui dis monsieur le sénateur en tout
cas je vais vous dire j'adore l'état
d'Arizona dis bon vous connaissez j'ai
oui oui je suis mal all à la Tombstone
dis ah bon vous êtes à la Tombstone ah
ça c'est incroyable dans l'avion de
kaboule il à la Tombstone ah bon où
est-ce que vous avez dormi parce qu'il y
a pas d'hôtel à Tombstone c'était la
question pièche un peu comme vous là
vous allez chercher où est-ce que vous
avez dormi à bisb bisb c'était une ville
à 40 km de Tombstone qui était à la
frontière qui était la capitale du
cuivre donc pendant 10 ans c'était une
mine de cuiv pu après ça s'est fermé et
à bisb vous avez le Copper Queen hôtel
qui est une espèce de réplique du Grand
Hôtel de Cabour dans le désert vous AZ
énorme et je dis bah forcément au copper
Queen Hotel dans quelle suite ben je dis
la John Wayne suite oh my friend il me
fait un HUG dans l'avion improbable et
je le revois un an plus tard un
pincefess à Washington
vraiment je pas c'était pas revu pu je
représente rien pour lui et il me voit
il me dity from the John way suite don
voilà Blueberry et pour le 3è
allez-y vas-y non allez-y votre coin
préféré aux États-Unis en dehors de
Tombstone
un truc qui vous a marqué al ça peut
être en ville dans la nature
il y en a beaucoup en fait
impression non mais c'est plus que ça
parce qu'en fait les Unis j'ai je me
suis fait un point d'honneur avant de
rentrer avoir visité les 50 états donc
je suis allé vraiment aussi pardon en
Alaska l'Alaska c'est c'est celui qui
est un peu faux parce que j'ai passé une
journée à uncorage donc c'est
techniquement exact et pas complètement
je peux pas mais j'étais à haw j'ai été
un peu partout dans le Dakota du Nord et
cetera
non il il y a le pendant de Tombstone
qui est comment s'appelait ah il y a une
série télévisée là-dessus pix non non
non non dans le dans le Dakota justement
ah oui ah
la la ville où wild Billy coock a été
assassiné durongo non pas Durango non
Durango c'est dans le Colorado ah c'est
horrible parce que je ne vois que ça peu
importe la ville où est enterré Calamity
Jane et wild Billy coock donc je suis
aussi allé dans cette ville et je suis
allé me recueillir sur la tombe de
Calamity Jane et W billyicock vous
montez à cheval oui pas pas
régulièrement mais j'aime bien oui monte
européenne ou américaine
euh je fais les deux en fait je suis pas
je suis pas cavalier j'aime bien les
chevaux et quand je peux je fais mais
j'ai pas je v pas faire du cheval tous
les weekendsquitation
mais non je fais pas d'équitation mais
un autre souvenir là aussi frustrant
toujours dans ce voyage qui commencé à
Tombstone on passe à monument vallleé en
décembre couvert de neige couvert de
neigeev non justement on arrive en
voiture on arrive dans le dans le motel
de la
de la de Monument Valley qui est le
Motel vous avez des champs avec à
l'époque les cassettes vidéos des films
de John Wayne que vous pouvez regarder
en voyant monum valally et donc là je je
je vais avec un indien navageo je je
vaer faire on va aller faire du cheval
c'éit extraordinaire c'était couvert de
neige donc aller au Galot sans aucun
risque c'était luukiluc le soleil
couchant le machin et cetera et ma
frustration c'est que à l'époque il y
avait pas d'appareil photo sur les
portables B je donne mon appareil photo
à mon guide qui a raté toutes les photos
dit c'est pas possible je suis là dans
Ball sur mon cheval et cetera et le myth
s'est effondré voilà il faut apprendre à
être modeste et à limiter ses attentes
vous avez fait Grand Canyon j'aime pas
l'expression ferme je suis allé
plusieurs fois Grand Canyon
vous baladez un peu ou faire du rafting
non alors j'ai j'ai une expérience
c'est mont Morya Deadwood pour la ville
Deadwood voilà merci oui Deadwood bah
c'est la ville effectivement de du
Dakota du Sud où là aussi de même qui
joue hckey Coral tous les jours à à
Tombstone il joue l'assassinat de Wild
Billy coock tous les jours à
à Deadwood et j'étais avec mon fils qui
a été embauché dans la dans la scène où
il il a joué dans la scène on assassine
wild billyicock donc on était les héros
français de ce petit village c'était
très très très amusant la Californie
vous avez fait un peu oui oui la
Californie je l'ai fait
je l'ai fait sous plusieurs espèces euh
j'y suis allé j'y suis allé en vacances
et je pardon je venis sur le Grand
Canyon mon expérience la plus
dévastatrice du Grand Canyon était la
première je voyagais à l'époque c'était
avec un ami on devait avoir 20 ans il y
avait un pass aérien où pour 400 dollars
on pouvait faire le tour des États-Unis
en étant en standby on montait dans les
avions quand il y avait de la place et
on arrive au grand Cagnon on devait
reprendre l'avion le soir Las Vegas
parce que sinon le Pass marchait plus et
on dit bah allez nous on est jeune et
fort on va faire le on va descendre dans
le Grand Canyon donc à 5h du matin on
descend à toute vitesse tout é puis
après il dit bah faut remonter et on
était au mois d'août j'ai cru qu'on ne
remonterait jamais on finissait presque
en rampant on avait juste un litre d'eau
c'est un souvenir de fou donc
heureusement après j'ai sur suru
plusieurs fois et des meilleures
conditions
un troisè livre
non un 3è livre euh
je je serais tenté de citer les mémoires
d'Adrien euh
alorsêtre frustrant parce que j'ai pas
cité de de de livres d'économie de
finances et cetera mais je crois que la
littérature est
elle nous apprend plus sur nous-mêmes et
sur le monde que que beaucoup de Liv
beaucoup de livr théoriqu est-ce que
vous avez un conseil pour les jeunes
générations une bouteille à la mer
quelque chose d'impérissable qui restera
sur les réseaux alors oui c'est ce que
je sais pas si ça restera sur les
réseaux faut être modeste mais c'est ce
que je dis j'essaie pas mal de soit
d'enseigner soit de rencontrer des
étudiants et je leur dis ce que ce que
je vais partager ce soir je leur dis en
fait à la fin de mon Inter invention
j'ai dit posez votre crayon fermez vos
yeux et essayez de vous demander de quoi
vous voudriez qu'on se souvienne en
parlant de vous dans 50 ans 60 ans il y
a pas de bonne réponse vous voulez
peut-être devenir l'homme le plus riche
du monde vous voulez inventer un vaccin
vous voulez être le père idéal ou la
mère idéale il y a pas de bonne réponse
mais c'est quoi votre rêve au fond de
quoi vous avez besoin de quel est le
quel est la chose qui qui va qui va être
votre moteur et moi je sais que mon
moteur quand j'avais 20 ans c'est dire
je veux laisser une trace positif pour
le monde je savais pas ce que c'était
j'ai même plutôt pensé à la politique à
l'époque mais c'est pas ce que j'ai fait
finalement et je dis aux gens voilà
gardez bien ce ce ce rêve là mettez-le
dans un coin euh et comme tous les rêves
euh bah c'est un cap c'est un phare et
si vous faites du bateau ou de la
montagne vous savez c'est rarement la
ligne droite mais vous tirez des bords
et vous pouvez vous éloigner de votre
rêv vous rapprocher mais posez-vous la
question tous les 2 3 ans est-ce que je
me suis plutôt éloigné ou plutôt
rapproché est-ce que je suis là où j'ai
envie d'être aujourd'hui et pour revenir
à ce qu'on disait tout à l'heure ne vous
mettez pas dans une prise pr on doré ne
vous dites pas je reste là parce que
j'attends la prochaine prime le prochain
bonus la prochaine promotion et cetera
et puis vous réveillez à 50 ans merde
c'est pas ce que je voulais faire en
fait je me suis trompé et je pense qu'il
faut faire vraiment attention de et et
dans un monde qui est vraiment en
attente de de de changement et cetera si
votre rêve c'est faire cette planète
soit meilleure j'espère que c'est votre
rêve bah faites-le n'attendez pas per
trambadr merci merci beaucoup
[Musique]